Hey everybody, so you might have heard the term Kubernetes or clustering or these kind of terms, containers and pods and kind of wondered, what is that? You know, that is a whole other universe, especially if you're in university, you might have a Kubernetes cluster at your university, but you're just a person who's using it. I bet your email server is probably running on a Kubernetes cluster you might not even know. And so we're going to really dive into what all of these things are and unpack them, which I think is going to be really, really exciting and super valuable. And to do that, we have Aran Khanna on the show. Thanks for coming on the show, Aran. Hey, thank you so much for having
大家好，所以你可能听过Kubernetes、集群（clustering）或者容器（containers）和Pod之类的词，心里可能会想：那到底是什么？你知道的，那完全是另一个领域，特别是如果你在读大学，你的大学里可能就有一个Kubernetes集群，但你只是一个使用者。我敢打赌，你的电子邮件服务器很可能就运行在Kubernetes集群上，而你甚至可能都不知道。所以我们今天要深入探讨所有这些东西到底是什么，并把它们拆解开来，我认为这会非常非常有趣，而且价值极大。为了做到这一点，我们请来了Aran Khanna做客节目。谢谢你来到节目，Aran。嘿，非常感谢邀请
me, Jason and Patrick. It's great to be here. Cool. Great. Yeah. So Aran is the co-founder of Archera, which is a startup that focuses on cloud optimization. And he is an expert on Kubernetes. And he's going to kind of really unpack all of it for us. But before we get into that, you know, Aran, like, how did you get started in tech? And what's been your journey like? Yeah, well, I can give you kind of the short version. I was born and raised here in Seattle around the time of, you know, the 90s boom in Microsoft, and then the subsequent boom in Amazon and AWS coming online, just as I was sort of coming up. But ironically, I had nothing to do with tech, didn't want to work in it. I was actually very into biology and synthetic
我，杰森和帕トリック。很高兴来到这里。太棒了，好极了。好的。那么，Aran是Archera的联合创始人，这是一家专注于云优化的初创公司。他也是Kubernetes的专家。他将为我们真正剖析这一切。但在我们深入探讨之前，Aran，你是怎么开始接触科技行业的？你的经历是怎样的？嗯，好吧，我可以给你讲个简短的版本。我出生并在西雅图长大，正赶上90年代微软的繁荣期，然后随后迎来了亚马逊和AWS的崛起，正好伴随着我的成长。但具有讽刺意味的是，我跟科技毫无关系，也压根不想在里面工作。我其实非常喜欢生物学和合成
biology, biotech, as it's now called. And I was doing an internship my senior year before I was going off to college in that space in a biotech startup working on algae, trying to engineer them to create biofuels. And my cycle times on my experiments were like three weeks and the algae would all die, the fungus would come in, like, it was just such a nightmare. You have to unpack this for us. So I've heard about this, but I think I've heard about this from like a Deus Ex video game or something. This is like a real thing. So yeah, so this is a real thing where you actually are working on algae that creates fuel. Yeah, explain that for us. It's fascinating. It was really interesting. I mean, the world of
生物学（现在被称为合成生物学，biotech）。在我上大学前的最后一年，我在那个领域的一家生物技术初创公司实习，研究藻类，试图通过基因工程改造它们来制造生物燃料。我的实验周期大约是三周，然后藻类全都会死掉，真菌会入侵，这简直是一场噩梦。你得给我们好好讲讲这个。我听说过这个，但我觉得我好像是从《杀出重围》（Deus Ex）这样的电子视频游戏里听说的。这居然是真实存在的事。所以，是的，这确实是真实存在的，你真的在研究能制造燃料的藻类。是的，给我们解释一下。这太迷人了。这真的很有趣。我的意思是，在过去的两三十年里，世界
biotechnology in the last two, three decades has really exploded thanks to computers and then a lot of the new techniques. I'm sure you guys have heard of CRISPR and things like that. But the net is now that we have genome sequencing at such a cheap level, thanks to all the innovation in that space, we can actually not only read the genome, but understand what pieces are doing and then targeted almost like programming, go splice out pieces of them, put in your own kind of genes that you want that organism to express. Obviously, it's much easier with single-celled organisms like bacteria, and then let them multiply. And you can get these edits essentially that are functional, that are driven by you as the scientist. But to me, I didn't realize it at the time,
生物技术由于计算机技术以及大量新技术的出现，确实迎来了爆发式增长。我确信你们都听说过CRISPR之类的事情。但归根结底，由于该领域的种种创新，我们现在能够以如此低廉的成本进行基因组测序。我们不仅能阅读基因组，还能理解各个片段的作用，然后像编程一样进行靶向操作，去把它们的片段拼接出来，植入你希望该生物体表达的自己的基因。显然，对于像细菌这样的单细胞生物来说，这要容易得多，然后让它们大量繁殖。你基本上可以得到由你这位科学家主导的、具有功能的编辑结果。但在当时我并没有意识到这一点，
that was just an instance, a very complicated instance of programming. It was like the equivalent of, you know, writing everything in assembly back in the day. But the cycle times, you know, even when you're writing an assembly, you could click a button and the thing would execute. And even if the clock speed was slow, you'd get a result by the end of the day. With this sort of quote unquote programming these cells, it would take weeks, even with these single celled organisms for the things to culture and grow and for results to come back. If the batch was bad, if you made a single-point error or something like that, the equivalent of missing a semicolon, you'd have to wait two weeks to go
那只是编程的一个实例，一个非常复杂的实例。这就好比当年用汇编语言编写所有东西一样。但实验周期，你知道的，即使你在用汇编语言编程，你点击一个按钮程序就能执行。即使时钟速度很慢，到了一天结束时你也能得到结果。而对于这种所谓的对这些细胞进行编程，则需要数周时间，即使对于这些单细胞生物来说，也需要数周时间来培养和生长，才能得出结果。如果这批实验搞砸了，如果你犯了一个单点错误之类的话，就相当于漏掉了一个分号，你就得等上两个星期去
figure that out and then come back and do the experiment again. It was a nightmare. But during my lunch breaks, I would go upstairs and talk to the guys working in Java on the genome sequencing and the computational side, and they were just tearing through. They know, they would get through 20 experiments a day, because all they had to do was hit the enter button, and watch the program run and execute and analyze the data. And so as I went to college, I'm like, look, you know, if I want to do something meaningful, build interesting things, what's a better way to do it, you know, a way where each iteration takes two to three weeks, obviously, it's much better now, you know, a decade maybe later, or something where I can click a button, get a result immediately, and then distribute it to the whole world over the internet. And that's actually how
找出问题所在，然后再回来重新做实验。这简直是一场噩梦。但在我的午休时间，我会上楼去和那些用Java从事基因组测序和计算方面工作的家伙们聊天，他们的进展简直势如破竹。你知道的，他们一天能做20个实验，因为他们所需要做的就是按下回车键，看着程序运行、执行并分析数据。所以当我上大学时，我想，听着，如果我想做一些有意义的事、构建有趣的东西，更好的方法是什么呢？一种每次迭代需要两到三周的方法——显然现在，十年左右之后，情况好多了——还是一种我可以点击一个按钮，立即得到结果，然后通过互联网分发给全世界的方法？这其实就是
originally a lot of my passion and the interesting projects I worked on came out. I taught myself JavaScript and took the intro CS class in college, had really nothing to do with touching the servers for a number of years, but wrote a lot of really interesting Chrome extensions around digital privacy, one of which actually got me fired from Facebook, which is a fun story. But I ended up doing a lot of interesting stuff on the data visualization and the JavaScript side before, you know, realizing there was so much interesting stuff going on on the server side. And that's when I got into working in the cloud vendors, understanding really the nuts and bolts of how the back end of these systems, these large web systems worked. And then really ultimately got into machine learning and Kubernetes and all the interesting things that I'm sure we're going to talk about later in the episode.
最初我的很多热情以及我所做过的有趣项目诞生的过程。我自学了JavaScript，并在大学里上了计算机科学（CS）的入门课。有几年时间，这实际上与接触服务器完全无关，但我围绕数字隐私编写了许多非常有趣的Chrome扩展程序，其中一个甚至让我被Facebook解雇了，这是一个有趣的故事。但在我意识到服务器端有那么多有趣的事情正在发生之前，我最终在数据可视化和JavaScript方面做了很多有趣的事情。也就是在那时，我开始在云服务商工作，真正了解这些系统（大型网络系统）背后的核心技术。并最终真正进入了机器学习和Kubernetes领域，以及我确信我们将在本期节目后面讨论的所有有趣的事情。
Very cool. So, okay, so you're doing the Algae thing as like a high school project? This is pre-university. Yeah, pre-university, high school internship, essentially. Cool. And then went to university, studied CS, and then you started off doing front-end work. And so yeah, let's dive into that. So you built a Chrome extension that got you fired. So what exactly is going on there?
太酷了。所以，好吧，所以你在高中时就把研究藻类当成一个项目？这是在大学之前。是的，大学前，基本上是高中的实习。太酷了。然后上了大学，学习计算机科学（CS），接着你从做前端工作开始。所以，是的，让我们深入探讨一下。你开发了一个Chrome扩展程序，结果导致你被解雇了。那么那里究竟发生了什么？
Yeah, that's a fun story. So originally, like I was saying earlier, the big issue with working in that synthetic biology field was the fact that, you know, one, it took so long to get iterations out. And then two, it was really difficult to share my work with the world, which is why I went to the other side of the spectrum and really started to dive into, you know, front end technologies. I loved getting something that users could touch and feel in their hands. And, you know, the last mile there is actually getting an application together. And luckily at the time, Chrome, Firefox, all of these browsers made it really easy without essentially having any experience on the server side to go and build a functional,
是的，这是一个有趣的故事。所以最初，正如我刚才所说的，从事合成生物学领域工作的一大问题在于，一方面，推出迭代需要太长时间；另一方面，很难与世界分享我的工作，这就是为什么我转向了光谱的另一端，开始真正深入研究前端技术。我喜欢让用户能够亲手触摸和感受某些东西，而那里的最后一公里其实就是把一个应用程序拼凑在一起。幸运的是，在当时，Chrome、Firefox等所有这些浏览器都让事情变得非常容易，基本上不需要任何服务器端经验，就可以去构建一个功能性的、
interesting web app. So I was playing around, you know, hacking on projects on the side during my time in college. And this was around 2015. I started to see and I was actually taking a privacy class at school at the time, taught by the former head of the FTC's technology division. So we were talking a little bit about privacy in class. And Facebook Messenger at the time was taking off around Harvard, the school I was at. And it was basically the primary way, 2014, 2015, for me and all my friends to communicate with each other.
有趣的网页应用。所以我在大学期间一边玩耍，一边在业余时间折腾项目。这大约是在2015年。我开始看到——当时我正在学校上隐私课，由美国联邦贸易委员会（FTC）技术部门的前负责人授课。所以我们在课上稍微讨论了一下隐私问题。当时Facebook Messenger在我的母校哈佛大学大行其道。这基本上是我和所有朋友在2014年、2015年相互交流的主要方式。
One of the interesting things that I recognized was that every time a message was sent from a mobile device, by default, a location would be attached to that message, whether it was sent in a one-on-one chat, a group chat, what have you. And so I started to think, well, you know, if I just go through this backlog of messages sitting here in my browser and just plotted them on a map, would that be enough data to actually, you know, essentially dock someone or de-anonymize their location history based on this weird default in Facebook Messenger? So this is, wait, I want to make sure I get this clear. So this is someone who's messaging you or are you somehow able to get other people's messages?
我发现的一个有趣的事情是，每当从移动设备发送一条消息时，默认情况下，该消息都会附带一个位置信息，无论是在一对一聊天、群聊还是其他什么聊天中发送的。所以我开始想，好吧，如果我只是浏览保存在浏览器中的这堆积如山的消息，然后把它们绘制在地图上，这些数据是否足以真正追踪某人的位置，或者根据Facebook Messenger中这个奇怪的默认设置来对其位置历史进行去匿名化？所以这是，等等，我想确保我弄清楚了。所以这是有人给你发消息，还是你不知何故能够获取别人的消息？
Well, if they message you or any group that you are in, by default, that message would have location metadata attached to it, unless they'd gone in and turned off the default, essentially. So, you know, having the skills that I newly acquired to go build Chrome extensions, go build JavaScript apps, instead of doing this with a piece of paper and a pencil and writing a blog, I decided, well, what better way to not only test this out, but to let users see for themselves if this is something they should go and turn off than to build a Chrome extension that just sits in your browser, sucks in all that data when you go to Facebook, and then plots it on a map. And I cheekily called it the Marauders map because I was using the internal
嗯，如果他们给你发消息，或者发给你所在的任何群组，默认情况下，该消息都会附带位置元数据，除非他们进去关闭了这个默认设置。所以，凭借我新获得的构建Chrome扩展程序、构建JavaScript应用的技能，我决定不用纸笔写博客，还有什么更好的方法来不仅测试这一点，而且让用户亲眼看看这是否是他们应该去关闭的东西呢？那就是构建一个Chrome扩展程序，它只会在你的浏览器里运行，当你访问Facebook时吸取所有这些数据，然后将其绘制在地图上。我俏皮地把它命名为“劫掠者地图”（Marauders Map），因为我是利用内部的
builds to track my friends around Harvard, the same way Harry Potter tracked his friends with the Marauders map around Hogwarts. know, Hogwarts. And, you know, released it, I was actually completely independently accepted for a Facebook internship on the News Feed ranking team that summer. And honestly, I thought this would be a benefit to the users, it would educate users, it would give them insight into, you know, what these defaults were doing with their data and give them the ability to understand if they wanted to turn it off. So I thought this was a net benefit to users, released it, it went viral, got, you know, over 120,000 downloads on the Chrome extension store, the Chrome web store. And then Facebook reached out and said, you know, please deactivate
版本来追踪我在哈佛的朋友们，就像哈利·波特用劫掠者地图在霍格华兹追踪他的朋友们一样。你知道的，霍格华兹。而且，你知道的，我发布了它。实际上，那年夏天我完全独立地被录用为Facebook新闻流（News Feed）排序团队的实习生。老实说，我认为这对用户是有益的，它会教育用户，让他们深入了解这些默认设置对他们的数据做了什么，并赋予他们了解是否想要将其关闭的能力。所以我认为这对用户来说是一个净收益，发布了它，它病毒式传播了，在Chrome扩展程序商店（Chrome网上应用店）获得了超过12万次的下载量。然后Facebook联系我说，请停用
it. And I did left up the code is open source, obviously, because, you know, started as an open source research project to start with. And then the day before my internship was supposed to start, I'd complied with everything, taken it down, etc. You know, the VP of engineering and the head of HR called me a lowly intern and said, Hey, you know, we're going to rescind your internship because you didn't act in the best interests of Facebook. Shouldn't be surprising now was pretty surprising in 2015. We all know now what the cultural issues at Facebook were. But you know, the experience there was really interesting, because I was actually motivated, I could see that the impact was made, I could see the product decision was changed. And even though the, you know,
它。我照做了，把代码开源了，很明显，因为一开始它就是一个开源的研究项目。然后在我实习开始的前一天，我已经遵守了所有规定，把它下架了，等等。工程副总裁和人力资源主管打电话给我这个小小的实习生，说：“嘿，你知道的，我们要撤回你的实习机会，因为你的行为不符合Facebook的最佳利益。”现在听起来可能不令人意外，但在2015年这相当令人震惊。我们现在都知道当时Facebook的文化问题是什么了。但你知道的，那里的经历真的很有趣，因为我当时很有动力，我能看到产生了影响，我能看到产品决策被改变了，尽管
I had to go and scramble and find a job afterwards, the experience really stuck with me. And I actually did a number of additional projects, such as building a Chrome extension to suck in the Venmo history, that's all public and, you know, build a map of transactions projects, such as building a Chrome extension to suck in the Venmo history that's all public and, you know, build a map of transactions and, you know, do some other interesting de-anonymization projects while I was working on the privacy research side before I moved over into machine learning research and then the cloud. Oh, I see. So, so yeah, what was your, how did you get your toe in the water on the machine learning side? Was that a, like a subsequent internship or what?
我不得不去四处奔波寻找后续的工作，但这段经历确实深深地触动了我。事实上我还做了许多其他的项目，比如开发了一个Chrome扩展程序来抓取Venmo的历史记录——这些全都是公开的——并建立了一个交易地图项目，比如开发一个Chrome扩展程序来抓取Venmo的历史记录——这些全都是公开的——并建立了一个交易地图，在我转向机器学习研究和云之前，在隐私研究方面做了一些其他有趣的去匿名化项目。哦，我明白了。所以，那么，你是如何开始涉足机器学习领域的？那是一个后续的实习还是什么？
Yeah, actually, this experience, you know, with Facebook, after being fired, I had to scramble and find a job. I ended up landing at a small startup with a Carnegie Mellon professor who was working on an open source deep learning framework called MX net, which eventually, you know, as we went through that, you know, that lifecycle, it became the open source Apache deep learning framework competing with TensorFlow and PyTorch. Before that, actually, right before working at the Facebook internship, I worked at Microsoft on the Azure team. I had some experience there. Then, lo and behold, after about a year and a half of developing MXNet with this team, I was going to go back and join them. AWS acquires that team and I end up going to AWS with them to build out the SageMaker suite of tools, as well as continue some of that open source work and the deep learning research I was doing with that professor.
是的，实际上，这次在Facebook的经历，在被解雇后，我不得不四处奔波找工作。我最后落脚于一家小型初创公司，与一位卡内基梅隆大学的教授合作，他当时正在致力于一个名为MXNet的开源深度学习框架。随着我们经历那个生命周期，它最终成为了与TensorFlow和PyTorch竞争的开源Apache深度学习框架。在那之前，实际上就在我去Facebook实习之前，我在微软的Azure团队工作过。我在那里有一些经验。然后，随后的事情正如你所料，在与这个团队一起开发MXNet大约一年半之后，我正打算回去加入他们。AWS收购了那个团队，我最终和他们一起去了AWS，去构建SageMaker套件工具，并继续我与那位教授一起做的一些开源工作和深度学习研究。
Oh, very cool. So I see. So you started. So that was a pretty big transition, right? So you go from working on front end, you know, JavaScript and, you know, kind of Chrome extensions all the way into MXNet, which is kind of the guts of like TensorFlow operations. I mean, you're talking like, like really low level, like C and all sorts of like SIMD and kind of OpenCL. Wow. That was a pretty big transition. How did you, this is really interesting. You know, how did you build, you know, so you know how to program, you have the basics,
哦，太酷了。原来如此。所以你开始了。这是一个相当大的转变，对吧？你从前端开发、JavaScript和Chrome扩展程序，一路跨越到MXNet，后者可以说是TensorFlow操作的核心。我的意思是，你在谈论的是非常底层的东西，比如C语言以及各种SIMD和OpenCL。哇。这真的是一个相当大的转变。你是如何——这真的很有趣——你是如何建立起——所以你知道怎么编程，有基础，
you've never done anything CUDA or OpenCL or whatever. What was day one like, you know, how did you build that muscle? Right. Day one was pretty brutal, but I will say that, you know, the year before I had transitioned had transitioned from the general CS track to more of the systems track. So in school, I had taken classes that were taught in C. Even our intro class was actually taught in C, but taken much deeper classes that were oriented around C programming. I took the operating systems class at school, which was really helpful for parallel computation and then really complex C programs that you had to put together like virtual memory. So coming in, I had battle scars. I knew that this was a different programming paradigm, like managing memory is nonsense when you're only operating in a JavaScript world, right? So having some of that coming in was obviously very useful. And then I actually
你从来没有做过任何CUDA、OpenCL之类的事情。第一天是什么样的，你是如何建立那种能力的？对，第一天相当残酷，但我得说，在我转行前的一年，我已经从通用的计算机科学（CS）方向转向了更多的系统方向。所以在学校里，我上过用C语言教学的课程。甚至我们的入门课实际上也是用C语言教的，但我上了更多围绕C编程的深入课程。我在学校选修了操作系统课程，这对并行计算以及你必须拼凑的诸如虚拟内存之类非常复杂的C程序真的很有帮助。所以刚来的时候，我带着战斗的伤痕。我知道这是一种不同的编程范式，当你在JavaScript世界中运作时，内存管理简直是无稽之谈，对吧？因此，带着其中一些经验进入这个领域显然非常有用。然后我其实
didn't purely study CS in school. I studied math as well. So having some of that pure math background is really helpful for the machine learning side because it wasn't just the low level programming, especially in a team of like it was three, four of us really working on it at the time in the startup. It was having the ability to go from that low level all the way to the high level. Like what is the mathematics that we need to implement here? Say, and how can we make it more efficient? What's kind of the net outcome? So having a lot of that framework was very helpful. And I think going in blind without
在学校里并不单纯学习计算机科学。我也学习了数学。所以拥有一些纯数学背景对机器学习方面真的很有帮助，因为这不仅仅是底层编程，特别是在一个由三四个人组成的小团队里，当时在初创公司里真的是我们在搞这个。它需要具备从底层一直贯通到高层的能力。比如我们需要在这里实现什么数学原理？比方说，我们怎样才能让它更高效？最终的结果是什么？所以拥有大量这样的框架背景是非常有帮助的。而且我认为，如果盲目地进去，
that low level understanding of memory management and, you know, programming in C, which obviously is very akin to what you're doing in CUDA, as well as the depth of understanding of, you know, real analysis and dynamical systems and, you know, measure theory and probability and statistics, at least basic statistics, very difficult to get your hands around what is this actual deep network that you're trying to implement. So luckily, I had both of those pieces, and then obviously took months and months of, you know, working in the GitHub, getting my PRs denied again and again and again, and reading and taking courses to really get to a point where I could be dangerous, so to speak. So it was a process, I'll tell you that. But you know,
没有对内存管理和C语言编程的底层理解——这显然与你在CUDA中所做的事情非常相似——以及对实分析、动力系统、测度论以及概率论和统计学（至少是基础统计学）深度的理解，你将很难搞清楚你正试图实现的这个真正的深度网络到底是什么。所以幸运的是，这两部分我都有，然后显然经历了几个月又几个月在GitHub上的工作，让我的PR（拉取请求）一次又一次地被拒绝，阅读并参加课程，才真正达到了可以“独当一面”的程度。所以这是一个过程，我得告诉你。不过你知道的，
at the time, I basically had lost my job. And I was trying to figure out what to do next. So it was a good use of time that summer, I will say. Yeah, totally. That makes sense. Yeah, I think MXNet is really interesting, because it's a difficult market to crack. I mean, TensorFlow has been around for a long time. PyTorch is really taking off. But the thing I liked about MXNet was that it wasn't, well, for a while, at least, it was really like a consortium of different kind of folks. It wasn't like a single sort of like owner or like single controller like there was for TensorFlow. And I think PyTorch actually, in my opinion, does a better job of kind
当时我基本上失业了。我在琢磨下一步该做什么。所以我得说，那个夏天时间没白花。是的，完全如此。这说得通。是的，我认为MXNet真的很有趣，因为它是一个很难切入的市场。我的意思是，TensorFlow已经存在很长时间了。PyTorch正在真正腾飞。但我喜欢MXNet的地方在于，它并不是——嗯，至少有一段时间，它真的像是一个由不同类型的人组成的联合体。它不像TensorFlow那样只有一个所有者或单一的控制者。而且我认为PyTorch实际上，在我看来，在
of getting feedback from the community. But I personally feel like TensorFlow, it's very clear that there is a single controller there and it's very difficult to sort of, you know, move the thinking in TensorFlow. Yeah, it's really interesting because that was my first real foray into open source projects, which I think obviously is very apt when talking about Kubernetes, which I think has some of the dynamics that I saw in that market,
从社区获取反馈方面做得更好。但我个人觉得TensorFlow，很明显那里有一个单一的控制者，而且很难去改变TensorFlow中的思维方式。是的，这真的很有趣，因为那是我的第一次真正的开源项目尝试，我认为这在谈论Kubernetes时显然非常贴切，我认为Kubernetes也有我在那个市场上看到的一些动态，
obviously at a much later stage in its evolution. But I would fully agree. I think, you know, on the spectrum, when we were starting, there was TensorFlow, which was really a closed ecosystem in many ways, even though it was in or, you know, in theory, open source, you could see the PRs that get accepted and rejected. And it was pretty clear what the zeit FAIR and how independent it's been, I think it's been much more amenable to outside contribution, to community contribution. In fact, when we were at AWS incorporating MXNet there, we created Onyx with the PyTorch folks as that open model inter-exchange. And that was something that explicitly TensorFlow was not into. So, you know, I've been through some of those quote unquote, open source battles before in that world. And,
显然它的演进已经到了一个非常靠后的阶段。但我完全赞同。我认为，你知道，在这个光谱上，当我们开始的时候，有TensorFlow，它在很多方面确实是一个封闭的生态系统，尽管它在名义上，或者说理论上是开源的，你可以看到哪些PR被接受了，哪些被拒绝了。时代精神是什么非常清楚。而FAIR以及它一直以来的独立性，我认为它对外部贡献、社区贡献要开放得多。事实上，当我们在AWS将MXNet整合进去时，我们和PyTorch的人一起创建了Onyx作为开放模型互换。而这是TensorFlow明确不愿涉足的。所以，你知道，我以前在那个世界里经历过一些所谓的开源之争，而且，
you know, I think it's interesting to see now that PyTorch has so much greater adoption, I think, because of the fact that it's been nimble and driven by the community versus TensorFlow, which, you know, really, for the longest time, just stuck with its declarative only approach, even though everyone's like, No, no, I want imperative. I want something like what MXNet offers or really what PyTorch ended up offering at the end to most deep learning scientists. Yeah, totally. And so now the third evolution of your kind of skill set is then going from, you know, this machine learning and vectorization and BLAS and all these things to services, you know, to clusters, Kubernetes.
你知道，我认为现在看到PyTorch获得如此巨大的采用是一件很有趣的事情，我想，正是因为它灵活且由社区驱动，而TensorFlow呢，在很长一段时间里，真的只坚持其仅声明式的方法，尽管大家都觉得，“不，不，我想要命令式的。我想要类似于MXNet所提供的，或者真正像PyTorch最终向大多数深度学习科学家所提供的那种东西。”是的，完全如此。所以现在你这种技能树的第三次演进，就是从这种机器学习、向量化、BLAS以及所有这些东西，走向服务，走向集群，走向Kubernetes。
And so what was that transition like? And what sort of motivated that? And then how did you build that set of skills? Yeah. So when we came in our MXNet team to AWS, essentially, we were in research mode. We're a bunch of researchers building an open source framework. And, you know, Amazon is a product shop. So're a bunch of researchers building an open source framework. And Amazon is a product shop. So it was eight of us and they're like, well, you guys got to go build a team and
那么，那次转型是怎样的？是什么推动了这一转变？然后你是如何建立起这套技能的？是的。所以当我们的MXNet团队来到AWS时，基本上，我们处于研究模式。我们是一群构建开源框架的研究人员。而且，你知道，亚马逊是一家产品公司。所以我们是一群构建开源框架的研究人员。而且亚马逊是一家产品公司。所以我们当时只有八个人，他们说，好吧，你们得去建立一个团队，并
ship some products. This was before SageMaker, which is what our team ended up shipping, as well as the suite of managed machine learning services and tools around that, like the model marketplace and DeepLens, which I actually pitched and led the team for. But generally, the whole ecosystem was pretty immature on the AWS side for machine learning. But generally, the whole ecosystem was pretty immature on the AWS side for machine learning, and we were the ones who were supposed to correct that. So with that kick in the butt, we went from being essentially an open source shop
发布一些产品。这发生在SageMaker之前，SageMaker是我们团队最终发布的产品，还有围绕它的整套托管机器学习服务和工具，比如模型市场和DeepLens，这个项目我实际上进行了推介并领导了团队。但总体而言，在AWS端，整个机器学习生态系统相当不成熟。但总体而言，在AWS端，整个机器学习生态系统相当不成熟，而我们就是本应纠正这一点的人。所以在被狠狠踢了一脚之后，我们从本质上讲是一个偏重研究的开源商店，
with a heavy bend on research to trying to productionize some of this. And I think that's where I really started to cut my teeth on what does it take to essentially get research projects, which a lot of these were at the time in 2016, particularly around the deep learning side, vision, the language, speech, synthesis, et cetera, and put that into a productized state that's at the bar of an AWS service. That was a lot of learning and talking with customers, going through iterations with some of our biggest customers, we thought were going to be great fits for managed machine learning on AWS because they had all their data sitting there.
转变为试图将其中一些东西产品化。我认为正是在那里，我真正开始真正了解：要将研究项目（在2016年，这其中很多都是研究项目，特别是在深度学习、计算机视觉、语言、语音合成等方面）转化为达到AWS服务标准的量产状态，到底需要什么。这需要大量的学习，与客户交谈，并与我们最大的几个客户进行迭代，我们原以为他们会非常适合AWS上的托管机器学习，因为他们的所有数据都放在那里。
Taught me so much about not just how to build services, but also how customers use them in unintended ways, the ways that you have to be really thoughtful about things like pricing, which is really what the company I'm working on now is doing, trying to help folks optimize AWS, Azure, Google service pricing, and then really be thoughtful about the performance semantics because people will use things in crazy ways at crazy scales that you cannot really comprehend until you actually see it done. So really going through from becoming, being a researcher and doing this, you know, vectorized machine learning stuff, low level implementations of deep learning kernels through to actually building teams and launching services.
这教会了我很多，不仅是如何构建服务，还有客户如何以意想不到的方式使用它们，以及你必须对定价等事情进行深思熟虑的方式——这正是我现在正在从事的公司所做的事情，试图帮助人们优化AWS、Azure、Google的服务定价，然后真正对性能语义进行深思熟虑，因为人们会以疯狂的方式、在疯狂的规模下使用各种功能，直到你亲眼见到之前，你是无法真正理解的。所以，这真正经历了从一个研究员，做这种向量化机器学习的东西、深度学习内核的底层实现，到真正建立团队并推出服务的过程。
I think that was the AWS training that I take with me now and really look to apply in building products widely, particularly focused on the space of cloud infrastructure. Cool. That makes sense. Yeah. And so I think that, you know, the experience that you had is one that can resonate with a lot of people where you get something kind of working, you know, the experience that you had is one that can resonate with a lot of people where you get something kind of working, you know, on your desktop. And now you have 1000 people who need it, you know, and if it's a library, I think you're fine, because you could post it on GitHub, you make a release and people download it, and it scales that way. But if it's a service, that's where it becomes really unclear. And I think you can kind of get in trouble in both directions. In one direction, you spin up a
我认为那是AWS对我的培训，我至今仍随身携带，并真正希望将其应用到广泛的产品构建中，特别是专注于云基础设施领域。酷。这说得通。是的。所以我觉得，你拥有的那种经历是能引起很多人共鸣的，你在桌面上弄出了一些能用的东西。现在你有1000个人需要它，你知道，如果它是一个库，我觉得你没问题，因为你可以把它发到GitHub上，发布一个版本，大家就可以下载，它就会以这种方式扩展。但如果它是一个服务，事情就会变得很不明确。而且我认为你可能会在两个方向上都陷入麻烦。在一个方向上，你启动了一个
huge database and you spin up your own virtual private cloud and you do all of these things. There was an article about Fast, this company Fast. There's some kind of like FinTech. Actually, they recently closed, but they had built all this infrastructure. And really, they could have run the entire company on like one EC2 instance, you know, because they just they really didn't need all this. They didn't have the kind of customers. Now, part of it, I mean, there's more to that story. I think there was a little bit of fibbing around how many customers they really did have and everything. But you see this where you can kind of over-engineer things,
巨大的数据库，启动了你自己的虚拟私有云，然后你做了所有这些事情。有一篇关于Fast的文章，就是Fast这家公司。某种金融科技公司。实际上，他们最近倒闭了，但他们构建了所有这些基础设施。而实际上，他们本可以用一个EC2实例运行整个公司，你知道的，因为他们根本、真的不需要这一切。他们没有那种类型的客户。现在，部分原因，我的意思是，这个故事还有更多内容。我认为对于他们到底有多少客户以及所有这些事情，可能存在一点点虚报。但你会看到这种现象，你可能会把事情过度设计，
and now you're paying this really hefty bill every month, and most of that is wasted. On the flip side, the biggest fear folks have is our page goes on Hacker News. Some random person posts our page on Hacker News, and a whole bunch of people check it out. And the experience they get is like just the spinning beach ball or something because our one server has completely died and blown up. So then there's this third orthogonal axis where maybe you don't even use that many resources, but just the way you've designed things has caused you to get an extraordinary AWS bill. Like what I'm thinking of is cases where you have AWS Lambda, like trigger loops or, you know, triggers itself. Recursive Lambda. We see that a lot, actually. It's a
然后你每个月都要支付巨额账单，而大部分都浪费了。另一方面，人们最大的恐惧是：我们的页面上了Hacker News。某个随机的人把我们的页面发到了Hacker News上，然后一大群人涌来查看。他们得到的体验就像是只有旋转的彩色小球之类的，因为我们的单台服务器已经彻底崩溃并瘫痪了。所以这里存在第三个正交轴：也许你甚至没有使用那么多资源，但你设计系统的方式导致你收到了高得离谱的AWS账单。我想到的情况比如你有AWS Lambda，比如触发器循环，或者（你知道的）触发器本身。递归Lambda。实际上我们经常看到这种情况。这是一个
really interesting pattern. Yeah. And you end up with like a hundred K Lambda bill or something. So, you know, we'll get to that third axis. I think there's a lot of content there, but looking at the first two, you know, Kubernetes was really designed to be able to handle those two gracefully. And so I feel like that was kind of the big motivation behind something like Kubernetes, but I'd love to know, you know, you probably know a lot about the sort of history. And so, I know that at Google, they had Borg and some of these things internally. And so, what was the motivation for Google to make Kubernetes? And do you have any sort of inside baseball? Oh, my God, do I ever? And it's something that everyone can go and watch right
非常有趣的模式。是的。最后你会得到一张十几万美元的Lambda账单什么的。所以，你知道，我们会讨论到第三个轴。我认为里面有很多内容，但看看前两个，你知道，Kubernetes的设计确实是为了优雅地处理这两个问题。所以我觉得这就是类似于Kubernetes背后的巨大动力，但我很想知道，你知道的，你可能对它的历史了解很多。所以，我知道在谷歌内部他们有Borg和一些类似的东西。那么，谷歌打造Kubernetes的动机是什么？你有什么内幕消息吗？天哪，我怎么会没有？每个人现在都可以去
now on YouTube, because there was this amazing documentary two parter on the history of Kubernetes that was put out, I think, late last year, early this year, we can add it to the show notes, I can send it to you afterwards. But yeah, everything I'm about to say just comes from that it is so well done. It is like professional, it's incredible. They talked to everyone who was part of the team. But, you know, it has a very interesting history. Because think at the time it wasn't clear that, well, first of all, they wanted to get into the cloud market. Amazon was already very well established. Kubernetes was one of these weird kind of internal projects that took a lot of fighting, as you see in the documentary, to actually get approved. And then to get the open source piece of it approved was another whole battle that they had to wage.
YouTube上观看，因为去年底或今年初左右，播放了一部关于Kubernetes历史的精彩两集纪录片，我们可以把它加到节目说明里，我稍后可以发给你。但是，是的，我即将说的所有内容都来自于它，它制作得太棒了。它就像专业制作的一样，令人难以置信。他们采访了团队中的每一个人。但是，你知道，它的历史非常有趣。因为想想看，当时还不清楚，首先，他们想进入云计算市场。亚马逊已经非常成熟了。Kubernetes是那种奇怪的内部项目之一，正如你在纪录片中所看到的，它经过了大量的抗争才获得批准。然后，让它的开源部分获得批准是他们必须进行的另一场战斗。
And I think the documentary does a really good job of going through that. But it wasn't a kind of a straight linear path. It took a lot of dings along the way. And, you know, took some instances, as you can see in the documentary, where the engineering team is like, look, we're just gonna, you know, with or without leadership, we're gonna have to go and build this thing, you know, and let the code speak for itself. So there's a lot of kind of interesting sub stories in there, but generally came out of Google, there was a strong bend from the team to make it open source from the start. And building a lot of the community around it, I think was, you know, kind of an uphill battle in the early days for them, especially because of the fact that they didn't do this as like an Apache open source,
我认为纪录片在展现这一点上做得非常好。但这并不是一条直线发展的道路。一路上遇到了很多挫折。而且，正如你在纪录片中看到的，有些情况下工程团队会觉得：听好了，无论有没有领导层的支持，我们都得去把这个东西造出来，让代码自己说话。所以里面有很多有趣的子故事，但它总体上源自谷歌，团队从一开始就有一种强烈的倾向要将其开源。围绕它建立庞大的社区，我认为对他们来说在早期是一场硬仗，特别是考虑到他们没有把它做成类似于Apache式的开源，
it was Google, it was owned by them, But there was an open source bend to it. Eventually, the CNCF and some of these more neutral organizations took it over. But it was a very interesting history where a number of Google engineers internally in a response to AWS and kind of the dominance that they were having in the compute cloud ideated on this project, had a lot of kind of back and forth battles to get it out the door as an open source version that anyone could use a board. And maybe it's worth stepping back and explaining what that system did. It essentially took a lot of these commodity machines running in the data center and using this new innovation of containers, which is essentially within a VM, within a virtual machine, on an
它是谷歌的，由他们所有，但它有一种开源的倾向。最终，CNCF和一些这样更中立的组织接管了它。但这是一段非常有趣的历史，谷歌内部的一群工程师为了应对AWS及其在计算云领域的统治地位，构思了这个项目，经过了一场又一场的拉锯战，才最终将其作为任何人都可以使用的Borg的开源版本推向市场。或许退一步解释一下该系统到底是做什么的，是很有价值的。它基本上吸收了数据中心中运行的大量廉价机器，并利用了容器这一新创新——这本质上是在虚拟机内部、在
actual machine, another layer of abstraction using cgroups, namespaces, and Linux to really isolate sets of processes from each other within the operating system. And using that new construct that had started to come out, I think this was in the early 2010s and started to become popular. This is a way to actually take that construct that people are using to run generic applications on any kind of VM, particularly Linux, you could make a Windows container and things like that were running on those VMs, and actually orchestrate them at scale. So instead of just getting the ability to go build a container and run it on a VM, which was, you know, great in isolation for giving you that homogenous environment to go execute an application, you were also able to coordinate these applications across many VMs
实际机器之上，利用cgroups、namespaces和Linux实现的又一个抽象层，从而在操作系统内部将多组进程彼此真正隔离。并利用开始出现的新结构，我认为这发生在2010年代初期并开始流行。这是一种真正采用人们用来在任何类型的虚拟机（特别是Linux，你也可以制作Windows容器以及在这些虚拟机上运行的类似东西）上运行通用应用程序的结构，并对其进行大规模编排的方法。因此，你不仅获得了构建容器并在虚拟机上运行它的能力，这在隔离状态下非常适合为你提供执行应用程序的同质化环境，而且你还能够跨多个虚拟机协调这些应用程序，
into much more robust, distributed applications that Kubernetes as a control plane made it really easy to manage as it started to mature. Yeah, that makes sense. So cool. Yeah, we'll definitely have to watch a documentary. But at a high level, what you know, what Kubernetes is doing is if folks remember, we had an episode earlier on Docker. But just to give a really quick recap, we have virtual machines, which are pretty heavy, right? I mean, they have the whole operating system installed. I mean, the operating system alone might be like five gig, right? And you have to, it's very hard to sort of pass these around.
将它们变成更强大、分布式的应用程序，随着Kubernetes作为控制平面逐渐走向成熟，它使得管理这些变得非常容易。是的，这说得通。太酷了。是的，我们绝对得去看那部纪录片。但从宏观层面来看，Kubernetes所做的事情是，如果大家还记得，我们之前有一期关于Docker的节目。但为了做一个非常快速的回顾，我们有虚拟机，它们相当沉重，对吧？我的意思是，它们安装了整个操作系统。我的意思是，光是操作系统可能就有5G左右，对吧？而且你必须，在它们之间传递非常困难。
And you don't, like with a virtual machine, you have sort of the state of the hard drive, but you don't really know how you got there. So the nice thing about containers is that you have this Docker file, the script, which tells you, okay, the first line is, you know, start with a, you know, default installation of Ubuntu or something. And then the second line is, you know, go ahead and apt get these, you know, 10 zillion packages. And that third line is, you know, start these services. And the fourth line is maybe expose this MySQL port so that I can access it from the outside. And so anybody anywhere can run that Docker file and get a MySQL server kind of up and running. And the nice thing is because a Docker file has a reference to either another Docker file
而且你不会，就像使用虚拟机一样，你拥有硬盘的状态，但你并不真正知道你是如何到达那里的。所以容器的好处在于，你拥有这个Dockerfile（脚本），它告诉你，好吧，第一行是，你知道的，从Ubuntu的默认安装或类似的东西开始。然后第二行是，你知道的，去apt-get这些成千上万个包。第三行是，你知道的，启动这些服务。第四行可能是公开这个MySQL端口，以便我可以从外部访问它。因此，任何人在任何地方都可以运行该Dockerfile并启动并运行一个MySQL服务器。好消息是，由于Dockerfile引用了另一个Dockerfile
or some base image, the Docker file itself and the container doesn't need to hold the entire OS in it, just needs to hold sort of the delta. So that's sort of Docker in a nutshell. Now we're faced with this issue of, okay, I have this way to create a container, but if I want to create, you know, a hundred of them and I want all hundred of them to be
或某个基础镜像，Dockerfile本身和容器不需要在其中包含整个操作系统，它只需要包含类似于增量（delta）的部分。这就是简而言之的Docker。现在我们面临这样一个问题：好吧，我有了一种创建容器的方法，但如果我想创建，你知道的，一百个容器，并且我希望所有这一百个容器都
in some sort of load balance or where now I have, you know, a hundred servers up and running and they're all able to handle requests and I want to be able to change that number from a hundred to 200, you know, there's a ton of complexity around that. And Kubernetes was designed to sort of handle all of that, you know, communication between all of these containers. So can you dive into a little bit of the sort of glossary? Cause I'm a little fuzzy on this stuff that there's, I think there's pods, right? There's a Kubernetes cluster. Well, there's containers as well. So, you know, you have maybe starting at the base level and moving up might be helpful. So the container, I think you did an awesome job of explaining.
采用某种负载均衡的形式，或者现在我有，你知道的，一百个服务器启动并运行，它们都能够处理请求，并且我希望能够将这个数字从一百改到两百，你知道的，这周围有大量的复杂性。而Kubernetes的设计就是为了处理所有这些，你知道的，所有这些容器之间的通信。所以你能稍微深入一下词汇表吗？因为我对这些东西有点模糊，里面有，我想有Pod，对吧？有一个Kubernetes集群。嗯，还有容器。所以，你知道的，也许从底层开始然后往上走会很有帮助。对于容器，我觉得你解释得太棒了。
That's exactly right. And people love containers because they're modular, easy to essentially recreate and great, you know, common homogenous places to run applications. So that's at the lowest level you have containers. One level above that, you have kind of sets of containers that are logically connected. And generally those are put into pods within Kubernetes. Those pods can then be grouped together within a namespace within Kubernetes. So this is all very abstract, we're not even touching the nodes and the instances and all that stuff yet. So you have containers, you have these logical groupings of containers in pods, you have the
完全正确。人们喜欢容器是因为它们模块化、易于重新创建，并且是运行应用程序的绝佳、共同的同质化场所。所以最低层是容器。在其上一层，是一组逻辑连接的容器。通常这些在Kubernetes中被放入Pod中。然后这些Pod可以在Kubernetes的命名空间内组合在一起。所以这一切都非常抽象，我们甚至还没有触及节点、实例以及所有这些东西。所以你有容器，你有容器在Pod中的逻辑分组，你有
namespace that is an organizational unit that can contain a set of pods for, say, an application. You have the SQL pods and the website serving pods that sit there together in a namespace for application A, for example. Or if you have a machine learning group that's using a bunch of GPU pods that can sit in application namespace B or something like that. From there, you actually can think about the whole cluster, which is really the set of nodes being managed by the Kubernetes agent on those nodes, plus the specific set of nodes
命名空间是一个组织单元，可以包含一组用于某项应用程序的 Pod。例如，你可能会让 SQL Pod 和提供网站服务的 Pod 一起放在应用程序 A 的命名空间里。或者，如果你有一个机器学习小组，正在使用一堆 GPU Pod，它们可以放在应用程序命名空间 B 中，诸如此类。从那里，你实际上可以考虑整个集群，它本质上是由 Kubernetes 代理在该节点上管理的节点集合，再加上一组特定的节点
that are the master, which has essentially the requirement to coordinate all of the nodes and the pods. And it uses this very interesting distributed database, collect CD to do that and keep track of state in a way where if any piece of that cluster fails, the abstraction of the namespaces, the pods, the containers is still maintained, you know, even if the nodes are potentially unstable or unreachable or something like that. So I think that's at a high level kind of the anatomy of a cluster. And then you can get into kind of the specific pieces like load balancing, if you want to stick load balancers in front of specific pods,
它们是主节点（Master），本质上需要协调所有的节点和 Pod。它使用这个非常有趣的分布式数据库 etcd 来做到这一点，并以某种方式跟踪状态：即使集群的任何部分发生故障，命名空间、Pod 和容器的抽象仍然得以维持，你知道的，即使节点可能不稳定、无法访问或诸如此类。所以我认为从宏观来看，这就是集群的结构。然后你可以进入到具体的部分，比如负载均衡，如果你想在特定 Pod 前面放置负载均衡器
like web serving pods, in case you have a spike in traffic or something like that, you want to make sure it all doesn't go to one machine to one pod. So those things are constructs in Kubernetes as well. Persistent volume claims, which is really attaching a disk into containers and pods, right? So they can have access to hard disk and not just the VM resources that technically aren't supposed to store state, they can be stateless, so to speak. And then you have these higher order operational abstractions like load balancers, where you have, you know, horizontal, sorry, not load balancers, rather autoscalers, where you have a horizontal autoscaler, vertical pod autoscaler, and a cluster autoscaler, which all serve different needs in terms of, you know, as you were alluding to earlier, making sure that
比如网页服务 Pod，以防出现流量激增或类似情况时，你希望确保所有流量不会全部涌向同一台机器上的同一个 Pod。所以这些东西也是 Kubernetes 中的结构。持久卷声明（Persistent volume claims），这实际上是将磁盘挂载到容器和 Pod 中，对吧？这样它们就可以访问硬盘，而不仅仅是技术上不应该存储状态的虚拟机资源，从某种意义上说它们可以是无状态的。然后你有这些更高阶的操作抽象，比如负载均衡器，其中有，你知道的，水平，抱歉，不是负载均衡器，而是自动扩缩容组件（autoscalers），你有水平自动扩缩容组件、垂直 Pod 自动扩缩容组件，以及集群自动扩缩容组件，它们满足不同的需求，正如你刚才所暗示的，确保
the number of nodes, the number of containers, the resources allocated to each container, all keep pace with the amount of load being experienced by applications in the cluster. So I know I went through quite a glossary there. Maybe it's worth stepping back and diving into each of those pieces a little bit. Yeah, there's a lot. Yeah, totally. Let's start with the autoscaler because I think something that's really fascinating. So actually, I take it back. Let's start with the load balancer because we kind of need to start there. So, you know, people, I'm sure some folks out there have used things like NGI and X and these other things that are independent of Kubernetes, where you can say, you know, if I get a request on this port, then 10% of them go to this IP address, you know, 90% go to this IP address. And so that seems
节点数量、容器数量、分配给每个容器的资源，全部与集群中应用程序所经历的负载量保持同步。所以我知道我在那里讲了一大堆术语。也许退一步深入了解其中的每一个部分会更有价值。是的，有很多。是的，完全是这样。让我们从自动扩缩容组件开始，因为我认为这是一件非常吸引人的事情。所以，实际上，我收回刚才的话。让我们从负载均衡器开始，因为我们某种程度上需要从那里开始。所以，你知道，人们，我确信外面有些朋友使用过像 NGINX 和其他独立于 Kubernetes 的工具，你可以说，你知道的，如果我在此端口上收到请求，那么其中 10% 会发往这个 IP 地址，你知道，90% 会发往这个 IP 地址。所以这看起来
pretty straightforward. What does Kubernetes offer? Is it still like you bring your own like NGINX or is it built into Kubernetes? How does that work? Yeah, so generally nowadays, you know, you'll have services managed Kubernetes services, you don't have to roll the whole thing and manage it yourself. So you'll have things like EKS and on AWS, AKS on Azure, GKE on Google Cloud Engine. And you're able to, just using those, actually have access to the native load balancers within those cloud vendors. So you don't have to go and roll your own NGINX load balancer container and spin it up and manage it. You can just say, look, give me the Azure load balancer, the Google load balancer, the AWS load balancer for this set of resources. So that's generally nowadays, given the maturity and all the managed service in the space, how folks will leverage those things.
相当简单。Kubernetes 提供什么？它仍然像是你自带像 NGINX 这样的工具，还是内置在 Kubernetes 中？这究竟是怎么运作的？是的，所以通常现在，你知道的，你会拥有受管的 Kubernetes 服务，你不必自己从头搭建并进行管理。所以你会拥有诸如 AWS 上的 EKS、Azure 上的 AKS、Google Cloud Engine 上的 GKE。通过使用这些服务，你实际上可以访问这些云厂商内部的原生负载均衡器。因此你不需要去构建自己的 NGINX 负载均衡器容器、启动并管理它。你只需说，听着，给我为这组资源提供 Azure 负载均衡器、Google 负载均衡器或 AWS 负载均衡器。所以现在鉴于该领域的成熟度和所有托管服务，通常人们会这样利用这些东西。
It's completely abstracted away as it should be, in my opinion. But fundamentally, it's not robust, obviously, than rolling it yourself, because this is our big managed services from these massive hyperscale cloud providers that manage traffic for Netflix and things like that. So they really scale up. But fundamentally, it's the same thing. As I get more volume, I'll report out on the volume I'm getting. So you can use that for intelligent decisions downstream. And I will segment that volume in a way that is not necessarily overloading any given resource within the cluster. Got it. Okay, that makes sense. So I see. So the individual nodes
它被完全抽象掉了，依我来看，本该如此。但从根本上说，它显然比你自己从头搭建更具鲁棒性，因为这些来自大型超大规模云厂商的大型托管服务为 Netflix 等公司管理流量。所以它们的规模确实很大。但从根本上说，这是一回事。随着我获得更多流量，我会报告我收到的流量情况。因此你可以将其用于下游的智能决策。并且我会以不会对集群中的任何给定资源造成过载的方式来分割这些流量。明白了。好的，这说得通。所以我想明白了。所以各个节点
have some way of telling the load balancer, you know, I'm in trouble, or, you know, I have a ton of work or I'm available. And then the load balancer then can, you know, send things to the right. So a pod is a group of machines, and the load balancer then can, you know, send things to the right. So a pod is a group of machines and the load balancer is always sending it to the same pod, but just to a different machine in the pod. Is that how it works? So it depends, right? Generally a pod is a group of containers, not machines. The machines are the actual nodes. So you can have multiple pods running on a machine with multiple containers within them. And the load balancer can be configured in different ways, but generally it could send it to, you know, multiple pods or a single pod that's scaling up or scaling down. There's kind of nuance in how you configure it.
有某种方式可以告诉负载均衡器，你知道的，“我遇到麻烦了”，或者“你知道，我有大量的工作”或者“我有空”。然后负载均衡器就可以，你知道的，将事情发送到正确的。所以 Pod 是一组机器，然后负载均衡器可以，你知道的，将事情发送到正确的。所以 Pod 是一组机器，负载均衡器总是把它发送到同一个 Pod，但只是发送到 Pod 中的不同机器。是这样运作的吗？这视情况而定，对吧？通常 Pod 是一组容器，而不是机器。机器才是真正的节点。因此你可以在一台机器上运行多个 Pod，其中包含多个容器。并且可以以不同的方式配置负载均衡器，但通常它可以将流量发送到，你知道的，多个 Pod，或者一个正在扩容或缩容的单个 Pod。你在配置它时有一定的细微差别。
It's kind of an open playground. is you'll have something like a vertical pod autoscaler and the load balancer would be sending to maybe two different pods or one pod that's scaling up, scaling down. Got it. Okay, so this is a good time to transition to that. So what is autoscaling and what is horizontal and vertical autoscaling? What does that distinction mean? Yeah, so horizontal autoscaling and vertical autoscaling, I think are pretty simple concepts when you think about it outside of like all this mess of containers and namespaces. Horizontal just means add more computers and vertical just
这有点像是一个开放的游乐场。你会拥有诸如垂直 Pod 自动扩缩容组件之类的东西，而负载均衡器可能会将流量发送到两个不同的 Pod，或者一个正在扩容或缩容的 Pod。明白了。好的，所以这是一个过渡到该话题的好时机。那么什么是自动扩缩容？什么是水平和垂直自动扩缩容？这种区别意味着什么？是的，所以水平自动扩缩容和垂直自动扩缩容，我认为当你把它们从所有这些杂乱的容器和命名空间中抽离出来看时，是相当简单的概念。水平扩展只意味着添加更多计算机，而垂直扩展只
means make the computer bigger. It's kind of the way I think about it. And those things are the same whether you're managing VMs or containers or whatever. Now, there's specific in Kubernetes horizontal and vertical pod autoscalers that you can put in to your cluster. And then you have a cluster autoscaler underneath all of that, which is actually managing the nodes. Because fundamentally, even if you have a vertical pod autoscaler that says, as this node becomes busy, you know, bump up the number of CPU cores it has. It might actually physically run out of the CPU cores on the machine, the node that it's running on. So it might need to add more nodes or make the node bigger. So you have a cluster autoscaler actually underneath all of these that are very specific to the cloud provider
意味着把计算机做大。这是我思考它的方式。无论你是在管理虚拟机、容器还是其他什么，这些东西都是一样的。现在，Kubernetes 中有你可以放入集群的特定水平和垂直 Pod 自动扩缩容组件。然后你在所有这一切的底层拥有一个集群自动扩缩容组件，它实际上在管理节点。因为从根本上说，即使你有一个垂直 Pod 自动扩缩容组件，它说随着该节点变得繁忙，你知道的，调高它拥有的 CPU 核心数。它实际上可能会用完它正在运行的机器（即节点）上的物理 CPU 核心。所以它可能需要添加更多节点或者把节点做大。因此，在所有这些底层，你都有一个专门针对云厂商的集群自动扩缩容组件
and can add and remove nodes based on the aggregate demand in the cluster. And then you have the horizontal pod autoscaler, which is just adding more containers, adding more pods as the load goes up. And generally the way to think about it is if you have a very parallelizable workload, like, you know, serving web requests where a lot of this stuff can be done in parallel, it's great to use something like a horizontal pod autoscaler and just have more replicas to load balance that load between. If you have something that is very serial and cannot be
并且可以根据集群中的总量需求来添加和删除节点。然后你拥有水平 Pod 自动扩缩容组件，它只是随着负载上升而添加更多容器、添加更多 Pod。通常的思考方式是，如果你有一个高度可并行化的工作负载，比如，你知道的，处理 Web 请求，其中很多事情都可以并行完成，那么使用诸如水平 Pod 自动扩缩容组件之类的东西就非常棒，只需拥有更多副本即可在它们之间进行负载均衡。如果你有一些非常串行且无法
parallelized easily, it might just be worth throwing, you know, a bigger node at it. Something that, say, requires a ton of memory to compute and is, you know, has these big spikes, like a machine learning workload that you need to load all the data in and then, you know, process it in some way all sitting on one node. Worth using the vertical pod autoscaler for that. But again, these things don't operate in isolation. They're happening together with multiple applications on a single cluster. And then the nodes under the hood need to actually react to it. And that's why we have a cluster autoscaler as well. It's adding, removing, and right-sizing nodes. And you have a lot of interesting projects that are coming out just in the last few years, like Carpenter from AWS, that's supposed to help
轻松并行化的任务，那么给它分配一个更大的节点可能更划算。有些东西，比方说需要大量的内存来计算，并且，你知道的，有很大的峰值，比如机器学习工作负载，你需要将所有数据加载进来，然后，你知道的，以某种方式进行处理，所有这些都放在一个节点上。为该任务使用垂直 Pod 自动扩缩容组件是值得的。但话又说回来，这些东西并不是孤立运行的。它们与单个集群上的多个应用程序一起协同发生。然后底层的节点需要对此做出实际反应。这就是为什么我们也有一个集群自动扩缩容组件。它正在添加、删除节点并调整节点大小。并且你有很多有趣的项目在过去几年中涌现出来，比如 AWS 的 Carpenter，它本意是帮助
solve this problem and make sure that you're getting the most optimal nodes from both the cost and performance perspective added and removed from your EKS cluster based on the demand of the HPA, horizontal pod autoscaler, and the VPA, the vertical pod autoscaler. Cool. Yeah. So horizontal autoscaling seems relatively simple. The way I would imagine it is you could look at, I guess, the delay in between the time a request arrives and when it can be processed by one of these nodes and then just continue to add more nodes. That seems to, it seems like I could understand how you could build a, like a Kalman filter or something to like, you know, or a PID controller or something to like use the horizontal auto scaling. Vertical seems really difficult, right? Because you have to, it's like if you run out of memory, it's almost too late at that point to say,
解决这个问题，并确保你根据 HPA（水平 Pod 自动扩缩容组件）和 VPA（垂直 Pod 自动扩缩容组件）的需求，从成本和性能的角度，为你的 EKS 集群添加和移除最优的节点。酷。是的。所以水平自动扩缩容似乎相对简单。我想象的方式是，你可以观察，我猜，请求到达的时间与这些节点之一处理该请求的时间之间的延迟，然后继续添加更多节点。这似乎，这似乎我可以理解你如何构建一个卡尔曼滤波或者类似的东西来，你知道的，或者一个 PID 控制器或者类似的东西来使用水平自动扩缩容。垂直扩展看起来真的很难，对吧？因为你必须，这就好比如果你的内存耗尽了，在那一刻说：
oh, I need more memory. Or, you know, it's like you might be halfway through the process and say, oh, let me start the whole thing over again with twice as many CPUs, but then you didn't really save anything because you already were halfway done. So like, how does the vertical auto scaling actually work? I mean, what sort of signals do you get back to actually do that? Yeah, so I mean, it actually is difficult. In fact, one of the big production use cases we run internally is a lot of Argo workflows, which is another layer of orchestration on top of Kubernetes for specific ETL workflows.
“哦，我需要更多内存”几乎已经太晚了。或者，你知道的，这就像你可能进行到了一半，然后说：“哦，让我用两倍数量的 CPU 从头重新开始整个过程”，但这样你实际上并没有节省任何东西，因为你已经完成了一半。那么，垂直自动扩缩容实际上是如何工作的呢？我的意思是，你究竟能得到什么样信号来实际做到这一点？是的，我的意思是，这确实很困难。事实上，我们在内部运行的大型生产用例之一是大量的 Argo 工作流，这是 Kubernetes 之上的另一层编排，用于特定的 ETL 工作流。
And some customers will just send us a ton of data and we have to scale up sort of dynamically the pods based on that. And it's difficult. We got a lot of crash back off loops and things like that when, you know, the pod runs out of memory or can't initialize. So it's, you know, I will sitting here with the experience of having run this thing. It's not a solved problem. Like, I'll tell you that the easiest thing to do is over provision, essentially for the peak in advance. And VPA is great at scaling things down, I found, but not so great at scaling things up, as you alluded to. And, you know, I have the scar tissue of a lot of failed clusters, and, you know, data that didn't populate on a backfill to prove that it's not a solved problem. And, you know, it's hard to predict the future, especially when you have large spikes in your workload requirements. If you have something
有些客户会直接向我们发送大量数据，我们必须根据这些数据动态扩展 Pod。这很不容易。当 Pod 内存耗尽或无法初始化时，我们遇到了很多崩溃循环（crash back off loops）之类的问题。所以，你知道的，我带着运行过这东西的经验坐在这里。这不是一个已经完全解决的问题。我会告诉你，最简单的事情是提前为峰值进行过度配置。我发现 VPA 在缩容方面非常棒，但在扩容方面没那么出色，正如你刚才所暗示的那样。而且，你知道的，我有许多失败集群的伤疤，还有未能成功回填的数据来证明这不是一个已经解决的问题。而且，很难预测未来，特别是当你的工作负载需求出现大峰值时。如果你有一些
like an easy sort of scale up, that's very linear and predictable, that's different than, you know, spikes of data coming in at arbitrary points, which I don't think there's any system, you know, short of just over provisioning to really handle that effectively. Scaling down is a different story, right? And great to save money, but if that comes at the expense of performance for a critical customer, that's a trade-off you as an engineer have to make. Yeah, that makes sense. I'm going to jump in here and interrupt our interview today to talk about our sponsor, Zencastr. Zencastr is an all-in-one podcast production suite that gives you studio quality audio and video without needing all that technical know-how. It records each guest locally, then uploads the crystal clear audio and video
类似轻松的扩容方式，非常线性且可预测，这与在任意时间点涌入的数据峰值是不同的，我认为除了过度配置之外，没有任何系统能够真正有效地处理这个问题。缩容则是另一回事，对吧？这对于省钱很棒，但这如果以牺牲某个关键客户的性能为代价，那就是你作为一名工程师必须做出的权衡。是的，这说得通。我要在这里插话，打断我们今天的采访，来谈谈我们的赞助商 Zencastr。Zencastr 是一个一体化的播客制作套件，无需所有这些专业技术知识，就能为你提供演播室品质的音频和视频。它在本地录制每个嘉宾的音视频，然后将清晰无比的音视频上传
right into the suite, so you have high quality raw materials to work with. Jason and I have been using Zencastr for programming Throwdown for a while now and it's a huge upgrade over the way we used to do things. It's so much easier and more seamless to have everybody join a Zencastr room and get individual audio streams for each participant which allows editing and mastering to go much more quickly. It just also feels like a better experience for all involved. I'm so happy that we have this new solution instead of the way we used to do things back when we first started. If you would like to try Zencast or to make your own podcast, you can get a free trial by going to zen.ai slash programming throwdown. That's zen.ai slash programming throwdown.
直接上传到套件中，这样你就有高质量的原始素材可供处理了。杰森和我为 Programming Throwdown 一直在使用 Zencastr，与我们过去的方式相比，这是一个巨大的升级。让每个人都加入一个 Zencastr 房间并为每个参与者获取单独的音频流，要容易得多、也流畅得多，这使得剪辑和母带制作能够更快地进行。对于所有参与的人来说，这也感觉是一次更好的体验。我很高兴我们有了这个新解决方案，而不是我们刚开始时使用的那种老办法。如果你想尝试 Zencastr 来制作你自己的播客，你可以通过访问 zen.ai slash programming throwdown 来获得免费试用。那是 zen.ai slash programming throwdown。
Back to the podcast. I remember a long time ago, but there was this machine learning job that I would run at a different company and we would always crash the first time because of the auto scaler. So basically, sometimes you crash twice. And so I think in the end, we ended up putting some kind of constraint saying,
回到播客。我记得很久以前，我在另一家公司运行过一个机器学习作业，由于自动扩缩容组件的原因，我们每次都会崩溃。所以基本上，有时你会崩溃两次。因此我想最后我们最终加上了一些限制条件，说：
don't even bother starting this job unless you have 20 gigs of RAM or something like that. But yeah, that comes to the, I think, to the other nice point of Kubernetes, which is when you're launching one of these pods, you can hard code what the memory and CPU requirements are. And the system, in theory, depending on how it's configured, will have to go and get those for you before you get the pod in. So that's generally how you, as a practitioner, as you were saying, get around those issues. You're not saying like, start this with an arbitrary amount and figure it out for me. You can say like, give me this much, otherwise it won't work, which I think is the model that most folks, if they're engineers and working on this, end up using instead of,
“除非你有 20G 的内存或类似大小，否则甚至不要费心启动这个作业。”但是的，这就引出了 Kubernetes 的另一个优点，我认为，那就是当你启动这些 Pod 之一时，你可以硬编码内存和 CPU 的需求是什么。在理论上，系统会根据其配置，在为你分配 Pod 之前去获取这些资源。所以这通常是你作为从业者，正如你所说的那样，绕过这些问题的方式。你不会说：“用任意数量启动这个并帮我搞定它”。你可以说：“给我这么多，否则它不会工作”，我认为这是大多数人，如果他们是工程师并且在这方面工作，最终会使用的模型，而不是
you know, trying to stick their finger in the air and tune it. Yeah, totally makes sense. Very cool. So, okay. So, so one thing we should talk about is, you know, how do machines communicate with each other? So, you know, you say I have this auto scaling group. And so at any given time, I have so many instances of this container on this pod. And so do people say, you know, I want instance 14 on this pod or like how to, you know, so if I have a a if I have a auto scale, you know, memcache server, and then I have another auto scale, you know, node, you know, back end. How do those things communicate with each other? I mean, is there like a special DNS or something or what happens here? I think you're leading towards the idea of a service mesh, maybe so we can get into that a little bit or I really don't know. I'm asking total ignorance here. I have no idea. So so yeah, well, so yeah, I guess maybe drilling down and up the stack, we can maybe start at the bottom this time instead of the most abstract, you know, these machines are naturally networked in the data center to some degree, right? They're all sitting right when you spin them up on a virtual private cloud, let's say like a VPC,
你知道的，去凭空猜测并调整它。是的，完全说得通。非常酷。所以，好的。那么，我们应该讨论的一件事是，你知道，机器是如何相互通信的？所以，你知道，你说我有这个自动扩缩容组。所以在任何给定时间，我在这个 Pod 上有这个容器的那么多实例。所以人们会说，你知道的，“我想要这个 Pod 上的实例 14”或者诸如此类，你知道的，所以如果我有集群，如果我有自动扩缩容的 memcache 服务器，然后我有另一个自动扩缩容的后端节点。这些东西是如何相互通信的？我的意思是，有没有什么特殊的 DNS 之类的东西，或者这里发生了什么？我想你是在引导人们了解服务网格（service mesh）的概念，也许我们可以深入探讨一下，或者我真的不知道。我在这里完全出于无知提问。我完全不知道。所以，是的，嗯，所以是的，我想也许通过上下钻取技术栈，我们这次可以从底部开始，而不是从最抽象的开始，你知道，这些机器在数据中心里自然地在某种程度上联网，对吧？它们都在你启动它们时坐在虚拟私有云上，比方说 VPC，
which is what the AWS construct is for this, where they have specific ingress and egress rules around the machines. So maybe they can talk out to the public internet, but only a few things can talk into them. So just from a security perspective, you have that first boundary around all the machines that are in the Kubernetes cluster. So then within that cluster, you then have the individual machines that are all networked to each other. When you initialize Kubernetes, it actually creates essentially communication between all of those nodes within the VPC. And there's a lot of complexity on how you can limit that and how you can orient specific applications and their networking semantics when you spin them up on certain pods. But generally, those machines are all networked together.
这就是 AWS 对此的构建，它们在机器周围有特定的入站和出站规则。所以也许它们可以与公共互联网通信，但只有少数东西可以与它们通信。因此，仅从安全性的角度来看，你就在 Kubernetes 集群中的所有机器周围有了第一道边界。然后在该集群内，你拥有相互联网的各个机器。当你初始化 Kubernetes 时，它实际上创建了 VPC 内所有这些节点之间的通信。关于如何限制这一点，以及当你将特定应用程序及其网络语义在某些 Pod 上启动时如何定向它们，有相当多的复杂性。但通常，这些机器都是联网在一起的。
Can you dive into that a little bit? I mean, so how do the machines discover each other? I mean, how does that work? Yeah. So generally, when you use something like, you know, COPS, if you're hand rolling the Kubernetes deployment yourself, or use EKS, a lot of that is just kind of handled for you in many respects, especially nowadays. I'd say AKS, GKE, all of those specific services, just adding the marginal node, very easy. You don't have to worry about discovery or anything like that. It's provisioned for you. The Kubernetes agent is added to it. It's all kind of done seamlessly in the back nowadays. There was, you know, back in the day when you're hand rolling it, you could still have to run into issues where you might have to go in, debug and reconnect things to the cluster. But now it's
你能稍微深入探讨一下吗？我的意思是，机器是如何互相发现的？我的意思是，这是怎么运作的？是的。所以通常，当你使用诸如 COPS 之类的内容时，如果你自己手动搞 Kubernetes 部署，或者使用 EKS，在许多方面，其中很多东西只是为你处理好了，尤其是现在。我会说 AKS、GKE，所有这些特定的服务，只需添加边缘节点，非常简单。你不必担心发现或任何类似的事情。它是为你配置的。Kubernetes 代理被添加到其中。现在后台所有这些都是无缝完成的。曾经有一段时间，你知道的，在早期你手动搭建时，你仍然可能会遇到问题，你可能不得不进去调试并重新连接集群中的东西。但现在它
pretty seamless. What's interesting is now on top of it, you have these things like Istio, which is a very popular service mesh. And essentially when you have a distributed microservices architecture, like a ton of different pods, like you were saying, talking to each other within Kubernetes, having a control plane between those services, because this is one level of abstraction above even networking the nodes together in the cluster, right? These are networking the pods and services together. You need a control plane where you can essentially write in metrics and discover sort of the
相当无缝。有趣的是，现在在它之上，你拥有诸如 Istio 之类的东西，这是一个非常受欢迎的服务网格。本质上，当你拥有一个分布式的微服务架构时，就像你在 Kubernetes 中所说的那样，大量的不同 Pod 相互通信，在这些服务之间拥有一个控制平面，因为这甚至比在集群中将节点网络连接在一起还要高出一个抽象级别，对吧？这些是将 Pod 和服务网络连接在一起。你需要一个控制平面，你基本上可以在其中写入指标并发现
certificates between these services. So then they can talk to each other within the cluster itself. And usually this is done by adding this kind of proxy, like Envoy, which is a sidecar that's deployed with each application. And then those all talk to each other, well, technically talk to the control plane and then talk to each other. And then it allows the actual applications on top of these machines, like the pods and the applications running within them to then all talk to each other and discover each other.
这些服务之间的证书。这样它们就可以在集群本身内部进行通信。这通常通过添加这种代理来完成，比如 Envoy，它是一个与每个应用程序部署在一起的边车（sidecar）。然后这些东西都相互通信，嗯，技术上是与控制平面通信，然后再相互通信。然后它允许这些机器之上的实际应用程序，比如 Pod 及其内部运行的应用程序，然后相互通信并互相发现。
So Istio is probably by far the most popular, you know, control plane service mesh for this, but there's a number of options out there. And, you know, again, you have to do the interesting thing about Kubernetes is abstracting away all the low level stuff, but it still has to provide essentially the same primitives, those low-level things like EC2 instances do. So you have this new realm of software for things that AWS provided by default, like service discovery and things like that.
所以 Istio 可能是目前为止最受欢迎的控制平面服务网格，但外面有很多选择。而且，你知道的，Kubernetes 有趣的地方在于抽象掉所有低级的东西，但它仍然必须提供本质上相同的原语，比如像 EC2 实例那样的低级东西。所以你拥有了一类用于 AWS 默认提供的内容的新软件领域，比如服务发现之类的事情。
Got it. So if I, let's say I have a service, let's try and like use an example here because I'm still trying to wrap my head around it. So let's say I have a node, let's start with like something really simple where i have a node server on ec2 instance and then i manually spin up another ec2 instance and run a memcache server and then my node server like you know hard codes let's say the ip address of the memcache server and asks for cache hits when it doesn't get it it it goes and hits a database. So it just
明白了。所以如果我，假设我有一个服务，让我们试着用一个例子，因为我仍然在努力理解它。假设我有一个节点，让我们从非常简单的事情开始，即我在 EC2 实例上有一个 Node 服务器，然后我手动启动另一个 EC2 实例并运行一个 Memcache 服务器，然后我的 Node 服务器，你知道的，硬编码了 Memcache 服务器的 IP 地址并请求缓存命中，如果没有命中，它就会去访问数据库。所以它只是
has to be another EC2 instance, right? So it's all hard-coded IP addresses. And so that makes sense. I can understand how that works, right? Yeah. Elastic IP1 talks to Elastic IP2, they never change. Exactly. Yeah. So if we want to move that to Kubernetes, so now my node server, what would I put in that location field for the memcache server? Is there like a, yeah, like, I mean, do I hard code the load balancer IP or something? Or like, do I ask it's CEO for that? I mean, like, what actually happens there? Yeah, so generally, you would ask, you know, the way this works is you would ask Istio for it because it manages the discovery of the services and within the cluster, that is. And if you have to do any service to service communication within the cluster, again, it could be living on any node.
必须是另一个 EC2 实例，对吧？所以它们都是硬编码的 IP 地址。这说得通，我能理解这是怎么运作的，对吧？是的。弹性 IP 1 与弹性 IP 2 通信，它们从不改变。完全正确。是的。所以如果我们想把那个移到 Kubernetes，那么现在我的 Node 服务器，我会在 Memcache 服务器的那个位置字段中放什么？有没有一个，是的，比如，我的意思是，我是硬编码负载均衡器 IP 还是别的？或者，比如，我向 Istio 询问那个吗？我的意思是，那里到底发生了什么？是的，通常情况下，你会去询问，你知道的，这的工作原理是你向 Istio 询问，因为它管理集群内部服务的发现。如果你必须在集群内进行任何服务到服务（service-to-service）的通信，同样，它可能生活在任何节点上。
So the IP, the load balance or all of that might change. And Istio and a service mesh generally is what keeps track of this in a distributed system, right? Especially where the application could actually be bouncing around between multiple machines. So that is sort of the main paradigm, at least in production, that folks will use to enable this service-to-service communication within Kubernetes. And I think it actually works across application clusters as well, but that's getting into another layer of complexity. In general, having this layer
所以 IP、负载均衡器或所有这些都可能会改变。Istio 和服务网格通常是分布式系统中跟踪这一点的方式，对吧？特别是当应用程序实际上可能在多台机器之间跳跃时。所以这是一种主要的范式，至少在生产环境中，人们会用它来启用 Kubernetes 中的这种服务到服务通信。而且我认为它实际上也可以跨应用程序集群工作，但这就进入了另一层复杂性。总的来说，拥有这一层
of misdirection through a service mesh is what allows you to go and discover and talk to services no matter where they may be located. Say the pod they were on fails and they had to migrate, this will keep track of all of that for you. Got it. So when my node code starts my Memcached client, before it can do that, it needs to have an Itzio, there's an Itzio like Python, sorry, Itzio node library or something. And it can somehow use that and ask Itzio, hey, I need the Memcached server. And maybe we assign a name to it. I need hey i need the memcache server and maybe there's we assign a name to it you know i need foobar's memcache server nitzio will come back with some kind of either a domain name or an ip address and i guess to your to your earlier point you can kind of register callbacks or something at it's you know and say hey if if foobar you know cash server dies
通过服务网格进行的错方向转发（misdirection），正是使你能够去发现并与服务对话的原因，无论它们可能位于何处。假设它们所在的 Pod 失败了并且必须迁移，这会为你跟踪所有这些。明白了。所以当我的 Node 代码启动我的 Memcached 客户端时，在它能够这样做之前，它需要有一个 Istio，有一个类似 Istio 的 Python 库，或者 Istio 节点库之类的东西。并且它可以某种方式使用它并询问 Istio，嘿，我需要 Memcache 服务器。也许我们给它分配一个名字。我需要嘿，我需要 memcache 服务器，也许我们给它分配一个名字，你知道，我需要 foobar 的 memcache 服务器，然后 Istio 会返回某种域名或 IP 地址，我猜根据你刚才的观点，你可以在 Istio 中注册回调或类似的东西，然后说，嘿，如果 foobar，你知道的，缓存服务器死了
or it needs to get swapped out or something let let me know. And while your program is running, Istio might ping you and say, hey, I have a new IP address. And then you know you have to blow away your Memcache client and create a new one with the new address. Yeah. And actually, the reason Istio can do that is what it's functionally doing is literally sucking in and logging all of the network traffic in and out of the cluster. So that's also an interesting leverage point. For example, in AWS, if you're just using EC2 instances to do this, you would have to go, if you want to do log tracing or network monitoring, things like that, you'd have to go and add something to each instance that is running the application. In the Istio case on Kubernetes, you install it once, it has access
或者它需要被换掉或类似的东西，请告诉我。当你的程序在运行时，Istio 可能会向你发送 ping，说，嘿，我有了一个新的 IP 地址。然后你知道你必须销毁你的 Memcache 客户端，并使用新地址创建一个新的。是的。事实上，Istio 能够做到这一点的原因是，它实际在做的事情是字面意义上吸入并记录进出集群的所有网络流量。这也是一个有趣的杠杆点。例如，在 AWS 中，如果你只是使用 EC2 实例来做这件事，如果你想做日志跟踪或网络监控之类的东西，你就必须去向运行应用程序的每个实例添加一些东西。而在 Kubernetes 上的 Istio 情况下，你安装它一次，它就可以访问
to all the cluster traffic. And then you can add things like, you know, APM or network monitoring, et cetera, on top of that in a really seamless, easy way. And just to dig in one step, the reason that the nodes can all discover each other is, and even discover Istio, is they have this Envoy proxy running on each of them. And that actually proxies the request to the right place, determined based on what Istio is saying is kind of the right place to route that within the cluster. So you have these two sort of components working together, one with this global view and one locally on each node
集群的所有流量。然后你可以在此基础上以一种非常无缝、简单的方式添加诸如 APM 或网络监控等内容。再深入一步，节点之所以能够互相发现，甚至发现 Istio，是因为它们每个上面都运行着这个 Envoy proxy（代理）。而这实际上将请求代理到正确的地方，根据 Istio 所说的在集群内路由该请求的正确位置来确定。所以你有这两个组件协同工作，一个具有全局视图，一个在每个节点上本地运行
to functionally make that dance happen and make those routes work. Oh, interesting. So, oh, that is interesting. So this Envoy proxy might actually handle the changing of the IP addresses for you. So you might not even have to regenerate your client, because the individual packets that are asking to get sent to this address, that resolution can change. Yeah. Sorry, I said it was deployed on each node. I meant it's deployed alongside each service that starts in the cluster and services running on the VM. But yes, that proxy is really the thing that's doing that work of kind of running. Oh, I see. Okay. Another thing you mentioned was a sidecar. What's a sidecar? Yeah. I mean, the simplest way to think about it is it's essentially something that's deployed alongside a container and an application. I'm getting into the details here.
来从功能上使那场舞蹈发生并使那些路由工作。哦，有趣。哦，那很有趣。所以这个 Envoy 代理实际上可能会为你处理 IP 地址的更改。所以你甚至可能不需要重新生成你的客户端，因为那些请求发送到这个地址的单个数据包，其解析可以改变。抱歉，我刚才说它部署在每个节点上。我的意思是它与集群中启动的每个服务以及在虚拟机上运行的服务一起部署。但是的，那个代理确实是执行运行工作的那个东西。哦，我明白了。好的。你提到的另一件事是边车（sidecar）。什么是边车？是的。我的意思是，最简单的思考方式是，它本质上是与容器和应用程序一起部署的东西。我在这里讲细节了。
It essentially allows you to do things, bundle some service like the proxy alongside the sets of containers that you're deploying for an application. It's called a sidecar because it's not part of the main kind of payload and application workload, but these are these sort of add-ons that should be deployed alongside them to make them work. In the case of Envoy, the proxy, it makes them actually network correctly within the cluster. Got it. And so Sidecar is also some kind of Docker container. And so every time you run your container on Kubernetes, it starts by Docker running all of the Sidecars and then it Docker runs your container all on the same VM.
它本质上允许你做一些事情，比如将诸如代理之类的服务与你为应用程序部署的一组容器捆绑在一起。它被称为边车，因为它不是主负载和应用程序工作负载的一部分，但这些是应该与它们一起部署以使其工作的附加组件。在代理 Envoy 的情况下，它使它们实际在集群中正确联网。明白了。所以边车也是某种 Docker 容器。所以每次你在 Kubernetes 上运行你的容器时，它都是从 Docker 运行所有的边开车开始，然后在同一个虚拟机上全部 Docker 运行你的容器。
Yeah. Within the same pod, it's essentially just another container that again, kind of not defined by you generally, it's the service like a Envoy proxy, something like that, that runs alongside the application container, which is defined by you in the Kubernetes pod. And just weird terminology, but it's just another kind of prepackaged container that runs in the pod to help your application out. Got it. So if I wanted to like, for all of my pods, for all of my containers, I wanted to get everything out of var log and put it on a database or something. So I would create a sidecar that does that
是的。在同一个 Pod 中，它本质上只是另一个容器，同样，通常不是由你定义的，它是像 Envoy 代理这样的服务，与你在 Kubernetes Pod 中由你定义的应用程序容器一起运行。这只是奇怪的术语，但它只是 Pod 中运行的另一个预打包容器，用来帮助你的应用程序。明白了。所以如果我想像，对于我所有的 Pod，对于我所有的容器，我想把 var log 里的所有东西都拿出来放到数据库里什么的。所以我会创建一个执行此操作的边车
and then attach that sidecar to all these pods. Yeah, I'm sure that's one way you could do it. You know, again, probably a better way, maybe do it in the application itself, but you know, to each their own. That's your castle in the sky to build, you know, just give you the bricks and all to do it.
然后将该边车附加到所有这些 Pod 上。是的，我确信这是你可以做到的一种方法。你知道，再次强调，可能有一种更好的方法，也许在应用程序本身中这样做，但你知道，各有所好。那是你要在空中建造的城堡，你知道的，（我们）只给你砖块和做这件事的一切。
Got it. Cool, cool. That makes sense. Yeah, this is super cool. And so what are some good resources for people who want to learn Kubernetes? Yeah, so I think that probably the best resources I found are kind of the tutorials on the official Kubernetes website. They have a whole list of those. And particularly, I think, you know,
明白了。酷，酷。这说得通。是的，这超级酷。那么，对于想要学习 Kubernetes 的人来说，有哪些好的资源呢？是的，所以我认为我找到的最好的资源可能是官方 Kubernetes 网站上的教程。他们有一个完整的列表。特别是，我认为，
the cloud vendors themselves, like AWS and, and Google with GKE, they have very great specific resources about spinning up and creating running toy applications with their specific managed services. I'd actually recommend starting there, particularly for folks who are more interested in kind of production use cases, because of the fact that, you fact that most production use cases of Kubernetes right now are being done through these cloud managed services. People aren't really rolling their own clusters and running cops anymore. As I alluded to throughout this episode, they have way, way easier ways to provision and manage these things now with managed services. So I would say, you could go to the official kubernetes.io site, the Cloud Native Computing Foundation, learn a lot there about the semantics of Kubernetes, how the paradigms
云厂商本身，比如 AWS 和谷歌（通过 GKE），他们拥有非常棒的特定资源，关于如何使用其特定的托管服务来启动、创建和运行玩具应用程序。我实际上建议从那里开始，特别是对于那些对生产用例更感兴趣的人，因为事实是，目前 Kubernetes 的绝大多数生产用例都是通过这些云托管服务完成的。人们不再真正自己搭建集群和运行 cops 了。正如我在本集节目中所暗示的，现在通过托管服务，他们拥有更好、更简单的方式来配置和管理这些东西。所以我想说，你可以去官方的 kubernetes.io 网站，云原生计算基金会（Cloud Native Computing Foundation），在那里可以学到很多关于 Kubernetes 语义的知识，以及部署和管理应用程序生命周期的范式是如何工作的。但对于实际去构建一个项目并做一些事情，你知道的，在世界上发布一个网站或服务，我会去 AWS 或 Google Kubernetes 引擎或 AWS Elastic Kubernetes 引擎的博客和文档，并开始从那里进行修改和编写，因为这绝对是开始的一个绝妙方式，并且能够真正处于正确的平台上，如果这个应用程序是你想要扩展的应用程序的话。是的，这说得通。
of deploying and managing application life cycles work. But for actually going and building a project and doing something, you know, putting out something like a website or service in the world, I'd go to the AWS or Google Kubernetes engine or AWS Elastic Kubernetes engine blogs and documentations and just start hacking from that because that's just a great way to get started and to really be on the right platform to scale up if the application is something that you want to scale up. Yeah, that makes sense.
实际上，我想深入探讨这一点，因为这有点违反直觉。很多人可能会想，让我先在自己的电脑上开始，让它在我的电脑上工作，然后再把它放到云端。但正如你所说，这里有，他们已经处理了，很多这些基础设施是独立于任何特定 Kubernetes 的基础设施。去一个已经处理了所有这些基础设施的地方，实际上会比你在家里启动一个 Kubernetes 集群要容易得多、容易得多。所以，是的，所以这有点违反直觉，但绝对地，你知道的，去这些公共云厂商之一吧。假设，你知道的，人们关心成本，特别是当他们在学习的时候，你知道，什么是，你知道的，对于某人来说，大致的成本会是多少？
Actually, I want to double click on that because that's a bit counterintuitive. A lot of people might think, let me start on my own computer and get it working on my own computer and then put it on the cloud. But to your point, there's the, they've handled like a lot of this is sort of infrastructure that is, you know, independent of any particular Kubernetes. And to go to a place that's handled all of that infrastructure is actually going to be much, much easier than you starting a Kubernetes cluster in your house. And so, yeah, so that's a bit counterintuitive, but definitely, you know, go on one of these public cloud providers. And let's say, you know, people are concerned about cost, especially when they're learning, you know, what is the, you know, what's like roughly what would it cost for somebody to learn?
你知道，假设他们不做任何非常昂贵的事情。对于某人来说，大致的成本会是多少，你知道，使用亚马逊或 AWS 学习 Kubernetes？是的，所以，而这正是我们公司工作的领域。但总的来说，你知道的，你可以在本地运行一些东西，有诸如 minikube 之类的东西，还有许多项目可以在你的 MacBook 或其他设备上实际运行 Kubernetes 命令和一个微型集群。但通常，你知道的，正如我们一直在讨论的，这的意义在于实际管理多个节点并在分布式环境中让事情运转起来，这在本地机器上运行是特别不可能做到的，特别是当你考虑到你在数据中心获得的所有网络连接和所有那些东西时。
You know, assuming they don't do anything really expensive for somebody to learn, you know, assuming they don't do anything really expensive for somebody to learn, you know, Kubernetes using Amazon or AWS? Yeah, so and this is literally where our company works. But generally, you know, you can run stuff locally, there's like minikube and a number of projects to actually run Kubernetes commands and a mini cluster on your MacBook or whatever. But generally, you generally, the point of this, as we've been talking about, is to actually manage multiple nodes and to get the thing working in a distributed environment, which really isn't as possible, particularly with all the networking and all that stuff that you get in the data center running on your local machine.
好消息是 AWS 实际上，坦率地说，相当便宜。如果你想做一个小型集群，你甚至不必管理自己的主节点。这正是这些托管服务版本的魅力所在，特别是像 EKS 和 GKE 这样的版本。你不必管理那个中央节点和跟踪一切的数据库。他们为你托管它。所以你真正需要支付的只是一些小的开销，比如主节点每月几块钱的控制平台费用，然后是你消耗的任何虚拟机资源。你可以坚持使用诸如 T2 micro 这种非常小的虚拟机实例，然后在上面花个可能是，比方说，每月 20、25 块钱顶天了，带有几个节点。所以你实际上可以启动那个分布式应用程序。所以不是超级贵。如果你是一名学生，AWS、谷歌，他们都提供免费计算额度。所以你可能可以
The good news is that AWS is actually, frankly, quite cheap. If you want to do a small cluster, you don't even have to manage your own master node. That's the beauty of these, specifically the managed service versions like EKS and GKE. You don't have to manage that central node and the database that keeps track of everything. They host that for you. So you're really only left paying for some small overhead, a few bucks a month for the control plane, that master node, and then whatever VM resources you consume. And you can stick to like the T2 micro kind of very small VM instances and spend maybe call it 20, 25 bucks a month max on this with a few nodes. So you can actually get that distributed application going. So not super expensive. And if you're a student, AWS, Google, they all offer free compute credits. So you could
获得 500 美元的额度，然后运行这东西一年，一年多还有免费计算额度。所以如果你只在云端运行几个小节点，你可能可以毫无问题地运行一年、一年多。而这正是你开发一个运行 2,000 个节点的应用程序的方式。所以你获得了绝佳的、高度可移植到大规模场景的实践经验，每月只需 20、30 美元。而且话又说回来，如果你是来自这些云厂商的学生，还有免费计算额度，这使得开始破解和学习这些东西的门槛真的很低。非常酷。太棒了。是的，我认为这非常合理。我认为这里有很多非常棒的资源。我知道帕特里克更新了节目
probably get $500 in credits and run the thing for a year, a year plus free compute credits. So you could probably get $500 in credits and run the thing for a year, a year plus with no issues if you're only running a few small nodes in the cloud. And that is the way that you'll develop an application that is running 2,000 nodes as well. So you get great experience, hands-on experience that is highly portable to large scale scenarios for that 20, 30 bucks a month. And again, free compute credits if you're a student from these cloud vendors makes it really low barrier to entry to start hacking on this stuff. Very cool. Awesome. Yeah, I think that makes a ton of sense. I think there's a lot of really great resources here. I know Patrick's updated the show
可能会获得500美元的额度，并运行该东西一年，一年加免费的计算额度。因此，如果你只在云中运行几个小型节点，你可能可以获得500美元的额度，并毫无问题地运行该东西一年、一年以上。这也是你开发一个运行2000个节点的应用程序时所采用的方式。因此，每月只需20到30美元，你就能获得非常棒的、高度可移植到大规模场景的实践经验。而且如果你是来自这些云厂商的学生，还有免费的计算额度，这使得开始捣鼓这些东西的门槛非常低。太酷了。太棒了。是的，我觉得这非常合理。我认为这里有很多非常棒的资源。我知道帕特里克（Patrick）已经更新了节目
notes. So folks can definitely check that out as well. Cool. So yeah, I think we did a really good job of covering the high levels here and getting folks what they needed to get started. So thanks so much for that, Aran. Oh, of course. And if you want to, you know, sorry, go ahead. Oh, I was going to say,
笔记，所以大家也绝对可以去看看。太棒了。所以，是的，我认为我们在介绍这里的核心内容以及为新手准备所需材料方面做得非常出色。非常感谢你，Aran。哦，当然。如果你想，你知道，抱歉，请继续。哦，我正要说的是，
so now I want to dive into Archeria. So imagine, you know, now you've built this Kubernetes cluster, you're scaling up, you hit front page of Hacker News. Amazing. You have tons of customers. You're building a thriving business on Kubernetes. And then you get hit with this $100,000 bill or something for the month. And you're like, oh my God, what happened here? How do we how do we deal with this? I can tell you on a much smaller scale. You know, I basically built a Google Photos for my family.
所以现在我想深入探讨一下 Archera。想象一下，你知道，你现在构建了这个 Kubernetes 集群，正在扩展规模，然后上了 Hacker News 的头版。太棒了。你拥有大量的客户。你正在 Kubernetes 上建立一个蓬勃发展的业务。然后你突然收到了一个 10 万美元左右的月度账单。你会想，天哪，这里发生了什么？我们该如何处理这个？我可以告诉你一个规模小得多例子。你知道，我基本上为我的家人构建了一个 Google 相册。
Like I built my own Google Photos when I was in between jobs. And it has like a little Android app and a site and everything. And I actually got hit with some surprise bills. I mean, nothing massive like that or anything. But I remember I'm trying to remember exactly what happened. I'm totally drawing a blank here. But basically, I ended up getting hit with like a $200 bill. It was something it was something Oh, okay, I got it. So I was using Datadog, which we've talked about in the past big fans of Datadog. But I didn't really know what I was doing. And so Datadog was logging like literally everything, you know, it's like if the OS, you know, allocated some extra memory to a swap buffer or something, Datadog had it right.
就像我在换工作间隙构建了自己的 Google 相册一样。它有一个小型的 Android 应用、一个网站以及所有相关的东西。我实际上收到了一些意料之外的账单。我是说，没有什么像那样巨额的账单。但我记得我在努力回想当时到底发生了什么。我的脑子完全一片空白。但基本上，我最后收到了一张大约 200 美元的账单。那是，那是，哦，对了，我想起来了。我当时在使用 Datadog，我们过去聊过，我们都是 Datadog 的超级粉丝。但我其实不知道自己在做什么。所以 Datadog 几乎记录了一切，你知道的，就好像如果操作系统给交换缓冲区分配了一点额外的内存，Datadog 都能记录下来。
And so I ended up getting hit with this like two or $300 bill, which I took a long time actually for me to figure out where the money was going. And because the Datadog thing was like a two or three click install. And so in the grand scheme of building this whole site, you know, I didn't really think much of it. And, and so I kept looking at my own code saying, Oh, I must, maybe I'm storing the photo like a thousand times or something. And it's like, okay, no, it's not S3. I mean, maybe it's like too many lambdas. No, that's not it. And then finally I figured out, Oh, it's this dataog sidecar, I think, or agent or something, which is just, you know, like costing me a ton of money. And so I can't imagine what it's like running a
所以最终我收到了这张两三百美元的账单，实际上我花了很长时间才弄清楚钱都花哪去了。因为安装 Datadog 只需点击两三下。所以在构建整个网站的宏大计划中，我其实没怎么在意它。而且，我一直看着自己的代码心想，哦，我肯定，也许我把照片存储了一千次什么的。然后我想，好吧，不对，不是 S3。我是说，也许是太多的 Lambda 函数？不对，也不是那个。最后我终于发现，哦，原来是这个 Datadog 的边车容器（sidecar），我想，或者是代理之类的东西，它正在花掉我大量的金钱。所以我无法想象经营一个
business and getting hit with that times a thousand. And so, so it's really cool that you span up this effort to try and help folks with that. And so why don't you dive into like, what inspired you to start Archera and what the company does? Yeah, so really, the idea from Archera came from my time at both Azure and AWS launching kind of the SageMaker services, particularly at AWS. I don't know if many reviewers have played around with GPUs on the cloud, but the costs are enormous, probably 5 to 10x the commodity compute like, you know, T2, T3 memory and compute machines that generally you're using for web applications and the kind of common web or cloud use cases.
企业并收到乘以一千倍的账单会是什么感觉。所以，你发起这项努力来帮助人们解决这个问题，这真的很酷。那么，你为什么不谈谈是什么启发你创立了 Archera 以及这家公司的业务是什么呢？好的，实际上，Archera 的创意源自我曾在 Azure 和 AWS 工作期间推出 SageMaker 服务的经历，特别是在 AWS。我不知道有多少听众在云端玩过 GPU，但成本是极其高昂的，通常是通用计算（比如 T2、T3 内存和计算实例）的 5 到 10 倍，而这些通常是你用于Web应用程序以及常见的Web或云用例的实例。
So incredibly expensive. And, you know, what I saw in the ecosystem in 2017, when we were starting to think about what our chair would be was the fact that there was great visibility, the tooling to show you where that spend is going, say to Datadog or something like that, if it happened last week or last month was pretty great. But the problem was that at the end of the day, a lot of the recommendations on how to act after, you know, where that spend is going was very nebulous. They give you five different recommendations that were often in conflict with each other. And then actually automating this thing, basically no one was doing it, especially the subset of recommendations that weren't
所以成本极其高昂。而且，你知道，我在 2017 年生态系统中看到的情况是，当我们开始构思 Archera 的形态时，事实是虽然有很好的可见性工具来展示这些花销去向，比如 Datadog 之类的工具，如果你想知道上周或上个月的花销，效果其实相当不错。但问题在于，归根结底，关于采取什么行动的许多建议，也就是花销去向之后的行动指南，非常模糊。它们会给你五个不同的建议，而这些建议往往相互冲突。然后要真正把这件事情自动化，基本上没有人这样做，特别是那些不影响
application impacting that may not need an engineer even to approve them. So I kind of saw this gap where visibility was great. There was a lot of visibility tools like Cloud Health, Cloudability, Cloud Checker, Cloud XYZ out there, and they were great at providing visibility, but failed to maximize savings. And at the global view that we got at AWS and Azure on, I think at the time, it was almost $300 billion of aggregate public cloud spend. It was estimated that about 33% of that was going to waste because of this gap between visibility and action. So what we started to think about is how do we create a platform
应用程序且甚至不需要工程师批准的子集建议。所以我看到了这样一个差距：可见性很好。市面上有许多可见性工具，如 Cloud Health、Cloudability、Cloud Checker、Cloud XYZ 等等，它们在提供可见性方面非常出色，但未能最大化节省成本。根据我们在 AWS 和 Azure 看到的全局视图，我记得当时，公共云的总体支出接近 3,000 亿美元。据估计，其中约有 33% 被浪费了，原因正是可见性与行动之间的这种脱节。因此，我们开始思考如何创建一个平台
where you can take that visibility, which frankly we view as a commodity and auto-tagging and classifying costs, but then actually build on it to build really detailed forecasts and use those forecasts to then govern the management of the cloud where it matters and automate the commitment purchasing, which is really this layer that we haven't talked about that's even underneath the EC2 and VM nodes in this stack from containers and Kubernetes all the way down to EC. And then uniquely automate the commitment management and then ensure the commitment. So if you don't use that capacity, we guarantee to buy it back from you.
在这里你可以利用那种可见性——坦率地说，我们认为这只是一种商品，包括自动标记和分类成本——然后在此基础上真正构建非常详细的预测，并利用这些预测来治理云管理中重要的地方，并自动化承诺购买（commitment purchasing），这其实是我们还没有谈到的这一层，它甚至位于 EC2 和 VM 节点之下，贯穿从容器和 Kubernetes 一直到底层的 EC。然后以独特的方式自动化承诺管理，并确保这些承诺。因此，如果你没有使用该容量，我们保证从你手中买回。
So instead of just providing visibility, we try and take the visibility that exists today and extend it with automation and use the predictability that that automation creates to actually share risk with our customers, to put skin in the game and actually ensure them that if their Kubernetes cluster scales down and we've committed to a bunch of capacity for them, we'll actually take those commitments off their books so they're not left paying anything. So that was really the model that we started our chair with. And we're about two and a half years old now, have a number of large public companies, including Fortune 500s
所以，我们不只是提供可见性，而是试图获取现有的可见性，并通过自动化对其进行扩展，利用自动化所带来的可预测性来与我们的客户共担风险，真诚投入并向他们保证，如果他们的 Kubernetes 集群规模缩小，而我们已经为他们承诺了一堆容量，我们实际上会把这些承诺从他们的账簿中移除，这样他们就不会留下任何付款负担。这确实是我们创立 Archera 的模式。我们现在大约两年半大了，拥有许多大型公共公司，包括财富 500 强企业
that we're working with, as well as tons of fast growing startups. And even in the toy example of running a Kubernetes cluster on the cheap, as cheap as possible, we have really small companies that we worked with where we'll say, hey, you want to experiment with this T3 node small cluster for three months. The rack rate on that, if you're just running it on demand, is say $5 an hour. We can do a three-year commitment for all of those nodes and get you a rack rate of say $2 an hour, much, much cheaper. But instead of you holding onto it for a full three years, after those three months where your project is done, you can either opt to keep that commitment month to month, or give it back to us immediately, no questions asked. And we take a small percentage of the kind of delta in savings to help customers sort of offset, to help us offset that risk and
我们在与他们合作，同时还有大量快速增长的初创公司。甚至在以尽可能低成本运行 Kubernetes 集群的玩具示例中，我们也有合作的小型公司，我们会说，嘿，你想用这个 T3 小型节点集群进行三个月的实验。如果你按需运行它，标准费率比如说是一小时 5 美元。我们可以对所有这些节点做出三年期的承诺，让你的标准费率降到一小时 2 美元左右，便宜得多。但是，你不需要持有整整三年，在这三个月的项目结束之后，你可以选择按月保留该承诺，或者立即交还给我们，无需任何追问。我们会从节省的差额中抽取一小部分比例，来帮助客户抵消一部分成本，同时也为我们提供一种商业模式，帮助客户解锁这种全新的选择权，以及我们通过这一创新战略能够提供的更深折扣。
give us sort of a revenue model to help customers essentially unlock this new optionality and the much deeper discounts that we're able to provide with this strategy that we've innovated. Cool. Yeah, that makes sense. So what is Archera's status as far, I mean, actually, it's been kind of interesting lately. There's been a lot of news about hiring freezes, right? There's, you know, Meta has this hiring freeze and Uber is claiming that hiring is a privilege. And so where's Archera there? Are you hiring? Are you hiring for interns, full timers, all of the above? None of the above? We're hiring for engineers, both intern and full time. So definitely reach out on our website, archera.ai. And yeah, we're looking for people who are anywhere from, you know, a little bit of experience, but want to learn all the way to like five, 10 years of experience running services and applications in the cloud.
酷。是的，这讲得通。那么 Archera 目前的状态是怎样的，我是说，事实上，最近挺有意思的。有很多关于招聘冻结的新闻，对吧？你知道，Meta 有招聘冻结，Uber 声称招聘是一种特权。那么 Archera 的情况如何？你们在招人吗？你们在招实习生、全职员工，还是以上皆有？以上都不是？我们在招工程师，包括实习生和全职员工。所以绝对可以通过我们的网站 archera.ai 联系我们。是的，我们寻找的人才范围很广，从只有一点经验但想学习的人，到在云端运行服务和应用程序有 5 到 10 年经验的人都有。
So really the whole spectrum. Cool. And if somebody, let's say, is going through that intro to CS, like we talked about at the beginning, and they're just ramping up in their career, what is something they can do on the side to give them the type of tools they would need to ace an Archera interview? Yeah. So I would say that the biggest thing is side projects. We test a lot of practical skills. So for example, if you have spun up and used a mini Kubernetes cluster to host an application before, if you have gone and built a, you know, we have front
所以真的是全方位的。太棒了。如果有人，比方说，正在经历我们一开始谈到的计算机科学导论课程，并且他们的职业生涯才刚刚起步，他们可以做些什么副业来掌握在 Archera 面试中脱颖而出所需的各种工具呢？是的，我要说最重要的事情是做副业。我们测试很多实际技能。例如，如果你以前启动并使用过小型 Kubernetes 集群来托管应用程序，如果你去构建了一个，你知道，我们也有前端
end roles as well. So gone and built a website with React or Vue.js, things like that translate to really hard practical skills that come out in interviews. And we do a lot of very practical interviews because we want people to hit the ground running on day one, no matter what skill level they are. So having that in your, you know, kind of back burner that you can pull on to speak to those project experiences is always really helpful. And then obviously there's this kind of standard coding interview stuff, but that's pretty generic. And I think maps across all companies, like making sure you have that data structures
岗位。所以去用 React 或 Vue.js 构建一个网站，诸如此类的事情会转化为在面试中体现出来的硬核实际技能。我们进行很多非常实际的面试，因为我们希望人们在第一天就能迅速上手，无论他们的技能水平如何。所以把这些作为你的后备经验，在谈到这些项目经验时能够侃侃而谈，总是非常有帮助的。然后显然还有这种标准的编程面试内容，但这相当通用。我认为它适用于所有公司，比如确保你在去面试之前进行过数据结构和算法的复习训练，类似这样的事情。
and algos review session before you go into an interview, something like that. Yeah have that data structures and algos review session before you go and do an interview, something like that. Yeah, that makes sense. And then for an end user, if someone is just getting started with Kubernetes, is Archera, does it have sort of a free tier or does it at the moment,
是的，确保在去面试之前进行过数据结构和算法的复习训练，类似这样的事情。是的，这讲得通。然后对于终端用户来说，如果有人刚刚开始接触 Kubernetes，Archera 是否拥有某种免费层，还是说目前，
does it have an option for those folks or is it really like not the right place for them? Well, we have a free tier. And as I said, we don't, even though we work with really large companies, we we have a free tier. And as I said, we don't, you know, even though we work with really large companies, we work with a lot of small startups as well. You know, we work with companies that were two people and we have a very generous free tier, you know, until you're spending like a million dollars a year, we're basically not billing you. And, you know, you can get started with cost visibility with this cloud insurance
它有没有为这些人提供一个选项，或者它真的不适合他们？嗯，我们有免费层。正如我所说，我们没有，尽管我们与非常大的公司合作，我们也有免费层。正如我所说，我们没有，你知道，尽管我们与非常大公司合作，我们也与许多小型初创公司合作。你知道，我们与只有两个人的公司合作，我们提供非常慷慨的免费层，你知道，直到你的年消费达到约一百万美元之前，我们基本上不向你收费。并且，你知道，你可以通过这种云保险开始进行成本可见性管理
stuff. That's very unique. And I think with zero time, zero engineering, SRE can save you a lot of money because the interesting thing is after the VM layer of the stack, you have these commitments that can basically change how that VM is built, but have no application impact. So by just automating that piece and providing insurance and helping you get more aggressive on that, fully in say four hours of work
这非常独特。而且我认为只需零时间、零工程，SRE 就可以为你节省一大笔钱，因为有趣的是，在堆栈的虚拟机层之后，你拥有这些可以从根本上改变该虚拟机构建方式的承诺，但不会对应用程序产生任何影响。因此，只需自动化这部分并提供保险，帮助你在这方面更加激进，完全可以在大约四小时的工作时间内
and max of plugging the thing in, evaluating it, maybe even having a conversation with one of our salespeople and then clicking the button is really quick. And it's all self service as well. If you want to do that, we support Kubernetes. And our goal is to make it as easy as possible to get high savings with the lowest risk possible, no matter what cloud vendor you're running. Very cool. I'll have to check this out. This is awesome. Yeah, this is great. So actually, before we close up here, what is something that is unique about working at Archera? So what is something that really stands out?
完成接入、评估，甚至可能与我们的销售人员进行一次对话，然后点击按钮，非常快。而且这也是完全自助服务的。如果你想这样做，我们支持 Kubernetes。我们的目标是，无论你运行的是哪个云供应商，都能以最低的风险最轻松地获得高额节省。非常酷。我得去了解一下。这太棒了。是的，这太棒了。那么实际上，在我们结束之前，在 Archera 工作有什么独特之处吗？有什么真正脱颖而出的地方？
Yeah, so you know, I think we grew mainly during the pandemic. So we're a remote first company, but we have a really great culture of getting together now, especially now that COVID is waning in person. So we've had some awesome meetups in Austin, Vancouver and Seattle. And we're a really fun company that I think is great to sort of, you know, have that, I think ideal, what I like to say is ideal kind of hybrid experience where you get the flexibility of being able to work from home. We have offices in kind of three major areas, Austin, Seattle, and Vancouver, but we get together a lot. And it's just an incredibly fun place from a kind
是的，你知道，我认为我们主要是在大流行期间成长的。所以我们是一家远程优先的公司，但我们有一种非常棒的聚会文化，尤其是现在 COVID 正在消退，我们可以进行线下聚会了。因此我们在奥斯汀、温哥华和西雅图举办了一些非常棒的聚会。我们是一家非常有趣的公司，我认为非常适合那种，我认为理想的，我喜欢称之为理想的混合体验，在那里你可以获得在家工作的灵活性。我们在三个主要地区设有办公室，分别是奥斯汀、西雅图和温哥华，但我们经常聚在一起。从开放创新的角度来看，这是一个令人难以置信的有趣地方
of openness to innovation perspective. We try and bring a lot of that Amazonian culture where anyone can create a document of what project they want to work on and what new kind of SKU or product customers would like. And we have a process for approving that and getting that into the workstream really quickly. So we love a lot of bottom-up innovation. Those are, I think, a few of the interesting things that we have at our chair that make it a really fun place for engineers to work. Cool. So give me an example of a in person thing that you did. That was really fun. Oh, well, we just did maybe two weeks ago, we did a big mini golf tournament at a bar here called flat stick in Seattle. That's a mini golf bar. So we have fun
我们试图带来很多亚马逊式的文化，任何人都可以起草一份关于他们想从事什么项目，以及客户会喜欢什么样的新 SKU 或产品的文档。我们有一个流程来批准该工作并将其非常快地纳入工作流中。所以我们非常喜欢自下而上的创新。我认为这是我们在 Archera 拥有的一些有趣的事情，使其成为工程师工作的绝佳去处。酷。那么请给我举一个你做过的线下活动的例子。那真的很有趣。哦，好吧，就在大约两周前，我们在西雅图一个叫 flat stick 的酒吧举办了一场大型迷你高尔夫锦标赛。那是一个迷你高尔夫酒吧。所以我们有有趣的事情
stuff like that going on all the time. You know, we're trying to make it a really fun thing for people to come into the office. Nothing is mandatory, but, you know, people come in because they love seeing each other and hanging out at least once or twice a week. And, you know, I think the fact that we're a small team and super innovative, like people use the whiteboards all the time, which is a great sign to me. People are always ideating and discussing stuff. And, you know, we love that, that site guys, we never want that to leave the company. Oh, very cool. That is awesome. I might have to hit you up for some advice of Austin things to do. Oh, yeah, we got quite a list there. Very cool. This is awesome. So if folks do want to get a you know, are interested in a career at Archera, is it
诸如此类的事情一直在发生。你知道，我们正努力让人们来到办公室成为一件非常有趣的事情。没有什么强制性的，但是，你知道，人们来这里是因为他们喜欢彼此见面，每周至少闲逛一两次。而且，你知道，我认为我们是一个小团队而且超级创新，这一点很有意义，比如人们一直都在使用白板，这对我来说是一个很好的迹象。人们总是在头脑风暴和讨论事情。而且，你知道，我们热爱那种心态，我们绝不想让这种心态离开公司。哦，太酷了。这太棒了。我可能得向你讨教一些奥斯汀值得做的事情的建议。哦，是的，我们那里有一大串清单。非常酷。这太棒了。所以如果大家确实想找，你知道，对在 Archera 的职业生涯感兴趣，是
archera.ai slash careers or? Yeah, I think archera.ai and then you go to careers yeah archera.ai slash careers that should have the latest link great well yeah this is amazing you know folks out there i mean we scratch the surface i mean kubernetes is an incredibly powerful tool but i think we did amazing job especially you are on did amazing job of kind of covering at a high level the way Kubernetes works, the way you can take an app that you have up and running maybe on your MacBook and be able to put it in the cloud at scale. So if you do get hit with hacker news number one or something, it doesn't blow up your infrastructure. And when that does happen and you need to keep track of your spend and you want to have a sort of, you know, have more confidence about your spend and how to improve it, you can check out Archera. And it sounds like, you know, for most folks out there, you can jump on the free tier, you can try it out
archera.ai/careers 吗？是的，我想是 archera.ai 然后你去 careers，对，archera.ai/careers 那里应该有最新的链接。太好了，好吧，是的，这太棒了，你知道，外面的朋友们，我是说我们只是略窥门径，Kubernetes 是一个极其强大的工具，但我认为我们做了一件了不起的工作，特别是 Aran 做了一件了不起的工作，从宏观层面介绍了 Kubernetes 的工作方式，你如何把一个可能在你的 MacBook 上运行的应用程序放到云端进行规模化部署。所以如果你真的上了 Hacker News 头版或遭遇了类似情况，它不会摧毁你的基础设施。当这种情况发生时，你需要追踪你的开销，并且希望对你的开销以及如何改进它有更多的信心，你可以查看 Archera。听起来，对于大多数人来说，你可以直接跳到免费层，你可以试用它
for, you know, trial period. And then if that looks like it works out for you, then you can continue using it. So it's sounding like an amazing product. Amazing time here talking about Kubernetes. Thank you so much, Ron, for your time. Thank you so much, Jason and Patrick. I really appreciated you having me on. This is a lot of fun. Cool. Excellent. And for folks out there, thanks again for supporting us on Patreon and through Audible. We really appreciate that. Thanks so much for your questions and comments. We've been getting a ton of email and actually a ton of people messaging Programming Throwdown on Messenger with stories about how they got into various things,
持续一段时间的试用期。如果看起来对你有用，那么你可以继续使用它。所以听起来这是一个了不起的产品。今天谈论 Kubernetes 的时光非常美妙。非常感谢你，Ron，抽空参加。非常感谢你，Jason 和 Patrick。非常感谢你们邀请我参加。这真的很有趣。酷。太棒了。对于各位听众，再次感谢你们在 Patreon 和 Audible 上对我们的支持。我们非常感谢你们。非常感谢你们的问题和评论。我们收到了大量的电子邮件，实际上还有很多人在 Messenger 上给 Programming Throwdown 发送消息，讲述他们是如何接触到各种东西的故事，
how they got into programming, how they started learning about Node.js and Next.js from talking to our chat with Guillermo. I'm sure we'll get some messages maybe six months a year from now about how people got into Kubernetes thanks to this cast. And it's so special when we get those emails. It's really, you know, it's honestly, it's why Patrick and I have been doing those for so many years. It's really special. And thank you so much for that, for that support out
他们是如何开始编程的，他们是如何通过与 Guillermo 的对话开始学习 Node.js 和 Next.js 的。我确信，从现在起六个月或一年后，我们会收到一些消息，讲述人们是如何由于这个播客而开始接触 Kubernetes 的。当我们收到这些电子邮件时，感觉太特别了。真的，你知道，老实说，这就是为什么 Patrick 和我多年来一直在做这些事情的原因。这真的很特别。非常感谢你们对我们的支持。
there. And we will catch everybody on the next episode. See y'all later. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in time. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们将在下一期节目中与大家见面。大家回头见。《Programming Throwdown》在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可证下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混编、改编，但你必须注明原作者（Patrick 和我）并在相同方式共享下发布。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。